ия
Lia
An der partido wird das Essen übergetreten.
Das war's für heute.
..
Ok!
Also ich weiß nicht wie weit ich mich heute konzentrieren kann, das sage ich euch gleich.
Es ist echt warm und es ist auch mit Klimaanlage nicht sonderlich angenehm.
Ja, also ich meine Klimaanlage ist dann kühler, aber du hast dann immer so einen Zug daneben, das ist alles nicht so geil.
Es könnte einfach aufhören warm zu sein, das wäre auch Pogge.
Wird es aber wahrscheinlich nicht, weil...
Ja, was trinken Leute? Hydrated. Hydrated stayen müssen wir.
Hydrated stayen. Stayed auch hydrated.
So, also Leute ich war heute morgen schon wieder 2 Stunden unterwegs.
Ich habe weiter abgenommen, das geht noch, noch geht das alles schnell, guckt mal.
Wubbl... Nee, nee, nee, das ist der Max FPS Twitch.
Nicht Wubblos, Wubblos, bin ich ja nur hier.
So, guckt mal. Massive.
Also wenn ich die Trends schon wieder sehe...
Oh, 96,3 erinnert euch, ich habe angefangen bei 108,5 Ende Februar.
Da geht schon was.
Diesmal habe ich extra darauf geachtet, dass ich mich liege in der Spiegelung, aber doch wiederum nichts liege.
Bald ein Strich in der Landschaft, ja bald ist gar nichts mehr von mir da.
96 ist zwar immer noch viel zu pepo fett, aber nicht mehr so pepo fett wie 108.
Nee, wie kommst du da drauf?
169,420?
Nee, ja wenn du es umdrehst vielleicht, aber...
Also bis ich bei 69,420 angekommen bin, dann bin ich wirklich nichts mehr vor mir übrig.
Wubblos ist fake, ja.
Wasseresser Massive Pork Subscription.
Ja, leider, leider, wir machen ein bisschen weiter an der gleichen Sache wie wir das letzte Mal weiter gemacht haben.
Guckt mal, ich zeige es euch ganz kurz und dann mache ich mal Updates.
Also wir hatten ja das letzte Mal hier aufgehört, guckt mal.
Wir hatten das letzte Mal aufgehört mit unserem C++ WebAssembly Zeug.
Ich zeige das auch gleich nochmal.
Die Hälfte davon kann ich wegschmeißen, was hier drin ist, braucht man wahrscheinlich gar nicht.
Also was aktuell geht ist, man kann ein x-beliebiges Videofile öffnen.
x-beliebig, solange der Codec von FFmpeg unterstützt wird.
Zum Beispiel das da oder das da.
Und ich habe es performanstechnisch geschafft, dass mein Browser abspielen kann.
Multithreaded, guckt euch mal an, hier oben.
Browser ist voll am abkacken.
1080p, 60fps schafft mein Browser zu decoden.
Ungefähr.
Na ey, ich sehe das ist ein bisschen, wie sagt man, choppy ist es, ist es, aber ansonsten ist das okay.
Ja, wenn ich 720p mache, 60 ist wirklich, da spielt er schneller ab als er müsste.
Die Konsolen-Log sind auch aufhören, doch.
Die habe ich aber noch gebraucht für Sachen, keine Ahnung.
Also, der schafft ein Video abzuspielen.
Und wohlgemerkt, ich muss das vielleicht an der Stelle nochmal kurz erklären.
Der spielt nicht einfach ein Video ab, der Browser.
Der spielt nicht einfach ein Video ab.
Der Browser bekommt das Video, decoded es mit FFmpeg von JavaScript nach C++ WebAssembly.
Decoded das Video und rennt es dann raus mit WebGL auf irgendeinen Canvas.
So.
Also das, was wir heute probieren, falls ich mir überlegt habe, ist folgendes.
Ich mache kurz Updates an.
Ja, hier wollte ich eh schon gerade machen.
Also was wir heute probieren ist, was anderes als H264 zu decoden.
Weil H264 muss ich im Browser nicht decoden.
H264 ist, na ja, das kann der Browser schon.
Das müsste ich eigentlich da drin gar nicht decoden.
Aber ich habe es zum Testen gemacht.
Mein Ziel ist ja, dass ich beispielsweise Videos decoden kann,
die der Browser nicht von Haus aus decoden kann.
Also H264 kann der Browser standardmäßig ja schon.
Wir machen MPEG2.
Genau, MPEG2 will ich decoden, weil dann kann man nämlich beispielsweise von TV Headend
sich streamen und Codecs abspielen, die der Browser nicht kann.
Ja, der Video-Tech kann nicht alle Codecs abspielen.
Der Video-Tech, also für ein publisches H264-encodedes Video,
in was der Browser decoden kann, ist der Video-Tech performanstechnisch
und insgesamt vom Händlinger natürlich besser.
Aber wenn der Browser einen Codec nicht unterstützt,
dann kannst du ihn nicht mit dem Video-Tech abspielen.
Und was ich hier mache ist, guck mal, ich decode ja wirklich die Video-Frames.
Also ich schicke die Video-Frames in den Decoder, bekomme das decodete Bild zurück
und dann rufe ich in JavaScript auf, Moment, das brauchen wir jetzt nicht mehr,
dann rufe ich diesen Callback hier in JavaScript auf,
der bekommt die Image-Daten und rendert sie dann raus in den Browser.
Ja, und du kannst dann abspielen alles, was FFMPEG decoden kann.
Genau, so das ist, Sekunde, ich muss mal kurz meinen Process Explorer aufmachen.
Habt ihr das mit Herzbleed mitbekommen, Leute, richtige Massive.
Was macht mein Vmware da gerade?
Das ist richtig pfeifert, achso man, vor allem man macht gerade Updates.
Habt ihr das mit Herzblitz, muss ich euch mal kurz zeigen, das ist wirklich...
Alter, was kriege ich denn da immer für Dinge?
Okay, Leute, meint ihr das Video hat so viele Views,
weil das ein cooles Spider-Girl-Cosplay ist oder wegen was anderem?
Boomer, oh man, die Short Thumbnails.
Herzbleed, ja, guckt mal, das ist Massive Pfeifert.
Ihr müsst euch, ich hab's aber auch auf Twitter geschrieben,
ihr müsst euch da keine Gedanken zu machen.
Ich hab mir das Paper mal im Schnelldurchgang durchgelesen,
das gucken wir uns jetzt hier nicht an, das ist ein bisschen viel harter Kost, ja.
Exquickmuffs.
Das muss man sich aber gar nicht so sehr im Detail durchlesen,
dass man halbwegs durchblickt, was da eigentlich Sache ist.
Und zwar, um was es da geht, ist Folgendes, ich versuch das mal kurz zu erklären.
Und zwar, die messen die Zeit, wie lange es dauert,
okay, ich mach wieder Dark Mode an.
Also, die messen die Zeit, wie lange es dauert,
bestimmte kryptographische Sachen auszuführen auf der CPU.
So, und nachdem aktuelle CPUs sich hoch und runter takten,
je nachdem wie beansprucht sie sind oder wie anspruchsvoll die Instruktion ist,
die sie gerade ausführen oder sowas in der Richtung, ändert sich das.
So, und wenn du jetzt ganz oft spezielle Berechnungen durchführst,
das ist wirklich die ganz light Variante von dem, was hier noch drin steht,
wenn du jetzt ganz oft spezielle Berechnungen durchführst,
kannst du anhand der Ausführungszeit Rückschlüsse darauf ziehen,
was ausgerechnet wurde, ohne dass du es selbst als Wert zurückbekommst.
Ursprüngsidee war dahinter, man kann ja den Stromverbrauch der CPU messen,
das gibt es ja schon länger, also du misst den Stromverbrauch der CPU
und kannst anhand des Stromverbrauchs von der CPU Rückschlüsse darauf ziehen,
was die CPU ausgerechnet hat.
Was ganz cool ist, wenn du beispielsweise irgendwelche Keys rauskriegen willst
und du schaffst es wirklich, dass die CPU exakt das ausführt, was du erwartest,
halt ohne dass du die verschlüsselten Sachen kennst,
und dann kannst du anhand des Stromverbrauchs ungefähr erkennen,
was hat er denn ausgerechnet, und selbst wenn du es nicht direkt eins zu eins
daran ablesen kannst, du kannst zumindest die Wahrscheinlichkeiten
so weit einschränken, dass du relativ schnell dahinter kommst.
Aber diesmal geht es halt nicht mit Stromverbrauch messen, sondern mit Timing,
also sprich wie lang braucht das Ganze, weil sich die Ausführungsgeschwindigkeit ändert,
unter anderem dadurch, dass die CPU sich hochboostet oder nicht.
Es ist nicht easy anzuwenden, es ist auch nicht praktikabel in der Ausnutzung,
weil du kriegst eine moderne CPU unter einem aktuellen Desktop-Betriebssystem
nicht dazu, das auszuführen, was du willst.
Guckt mal in Prozess Explorer.
Wie will hier jemand allen Ernstes irgendwas auslesen mit Timing?
Der weiß weder, also eines der Hauptpunkte in diesem beschriebenen Angriffsszenario
ist ja, dass du das auch remote machen kannst, also du kannst remote irgendwas
an den Rechner schicken und anhand der Ausführungsgeschwindigkeit
irgendwie so ungefähr Pi mal Daumen sagen, was der denn jetzt wohl gemacht hat.
Auf der anderen Seite kannst du es wiederum, also könntest du, wenn du
ein Echtzeitbetriebssystem hättest, was exakt diese eine Sache ausführt
in der Art und Weise, wie du das erwartest, was aber ja nicht so ist.
Aktuelle CPUs auf aktuellen Betriebssystemen, die führen
hunderte Prozesse aus über Multithreading, das wird hin und her gescheduled zwischen CPU Kern.
Du hast realistisch betrachtet eigentlich keine Chance, das auszunutzen.
Trotzdem ist das ein äußerst fifeheadiger Angriff, finde ich.
Leute, ich sauf irgendwie schon die 50. Wasserflasche heute.
Also an sich ist der Angriff wirklich, finde ich, ziemlich clever.
Praktisch, ich finde es ein bisschen übertrieben.
Sie zeigen natürlich schon, dass das alles ausgenutzt werden kann und sonst was.
Wobei es ist halt auch zugeben, dass das unter ziemlich optimale Laborbedingungen passiert.
Ach so, ja, übrigens, ja, stimmt.
Wenn man den Boost ausschaltet von der CPU, dann hat man gar keine Probleme mehr.
Aber wie gesagt, man muss sich eh keine Gedanken darüber machen.
Also ich finde, das ist nicht praktisch ausnutzbar.
Was auch ein wenig dadurch bestärkt wird, dass sowohl AMD als auch Intel,
guckt mal hier, steht hier glaube ich sogar drin,
dass sowohl AMD als auch Intel keine Patches irgendwie veröffentlichen wollen.
Ich meine, sie können ja auch nicht wirklich was dagegen machen, realistisch betrachtet.
Was sollen sie denn machen? Den Boost-Takt randomisieren oder den Boost disablen?
Dass du dann einfach mal 30% weniger CPU-Leistung hast?
Das kannst du den Leuten doch nicht erklären, das kannst du den Leuten doch nicht verkaufen.
Oh, hat es gerade geruckelt. Was ist hier los?
Drop Frames? Nein, nichts, Drop Frames.
Wo da Pepega war am Start.
Also, das könnt ihr eigentlich gedroht vergessen.
Interessant ist es allemal, was ich jetzt ein bisschen interessant finde,
wenn man sich hier anschaut, was die Leute...
Ich habe gestern mal geguckt, was die Leute auf Twitter posten.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich mich trauen soll, das mal in die Twitter-Suche einzugeben,
ohne dass ich jetzt gleich fette Bubas kriege und gebannt werde.
Don't Panic? Ja, das habe ich gestern schon vor 20 Stunden gesagt.
Essen hat Feiertag? Ja, ich habe frei heute.
Also, auf Twitter wird auch relativ viel Blödsinn geschrieben.
Auf News-Seiten wird auch relativ viel Blödsinn geschrieben,
wobei Kashi wieder relativ gut ist.
Weiß nicht, was für ein Kerl ist, aber der schreibt meistens relativ sinnvolle Sachen.
Heise ist im Prinzip, die haben im Prinzip wieder nur dieses Paper,
Abstract und ein bisschen hier was übersetzt und eigentlich keine Ahnung von dem, was sie schreiben.
Zumindest wirkt das so.
Aber viele Seiten schreiben komische Sachen.
Ich habe beispielsweise auch einen News-Artikel gelesen, der hat irgendwie was geschrieben.
Erst war Heartbleed, jetzt ist Herzbleed.
Mit dem Unterschied, dass das zwei komplett unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe sind.
Also, Herzbleed hat eher was noch mit Meltdown zu tun, als mit Heartbleed.
Und auch nur im Geiste irgendwie vom Ansatz her.
Manchmal habe ich echt das Gefühl, die News-Poster da haben keine Ahnung, was sie da schreiben.
Also, ich will jetzt nicht behaupten, ich hätte es komplett verstanden.
Ich habe das ganze Paper auch wirklich nur ziemlich zackig drüber gelesen, so 20 Minuten.
Es ist zwischenzeitlich, also wen das interessiert, kann sich das hier angucken.
Es ist äußerst pfeifertig.
Sie zeigen hier zwischenzeitlich auch, wie sie gucken an einer CPU-Frequenz.
Und dann gucken sie bei Berechnung, wie verläuft die CPU-Frequenz.
Und dann können sie sagen, wenn sich der Ready-State ändert, kann man das ungefähr zuordnen.
Diesen Berechnung.
Für die Pfeife hätte er noch irgendwelche Assembly-Sachen zwischendurch.
Und dann zeigen sie, wie man hier ungefähr erahnen kann, was die CPU berechnet hat.
Anhand der Frequenzwechsel und anhand der Geschwindigkeit, wie was gemacht wurde.
Also Pfeife hätte Zeug unter Laborbedingungen.
Okay, praktisch gesehen eher nicht.
Das funktioniert gar nicht, realistisch betrachtet.
Also, theoretisch funktioniert es Remote und Lokal.
Praktisch gesehen wird das wahrscheinlich Remote auf gar keinen Fall.
Und Lokal auch nur, naja, eher nicht funktionieren.
Weil du musst ja genau wissen, was der Rechner ausführt.
Dass du überhaupt anhand dessen, was du ihm quasi sagst, was er berechnen soll.
Und dem Boosttag und der Ausführungsgeschwindigkeit irgendwas dir ableiten kannst, was er denn berechnet haben könnte.
Was du halt nicht kannst auf einem modernen Multithreading-Betriebssystem.
Ich meine, guck mal, mein Rechner macht jetzt nichts so wirklich.
Und trotzdem, das Ding wird scheduled über zig CPUs.
Und selbst wenn du es pinst, selbst wenn du es pinst, ist hier ausführungstechnisch das nicht so genau, dass du es ausnutzen könntest.
Ist in der Linux in dem Fall auch nicht viel anders.
Also, ich würde sagen, man muss sich nicht viel Gedanken machen.
Log4j war um ein vielfaches Besorgnis erregender.
Sind eigentlich meine Updates fertig, dass wir anfangen können?
Updates fertig, das da.
Ich mache jetzt mal, ich update mal komplett durch, das muss ab und zu mal sein.
Gucken, ob hier alles geupdatet hat.
Chat, war ihr heute schon mal draußen oder habt ihr wie ich im Keller gehockt?
Nee, das stimmt nicht, ich hab nicht im Keller gehockt.
Ich war halt zwei Stunden laufen schon, aber früher hätte ich im Keller gehockt den ganzen Tag.
Mit laufen meine ich wirklich laufen, ja.
Nicht rennen oder so, laufen.
Walken.
Alles geupdatet.
Gehen, ich war gehen.
Man nennt das auf Deutsch halt laufen.
Also ich war nicht joggen, ich war wirklich laufen.
Ganz normal laufen.
Zwei Stunden wandern.
Im Spessart wieder.
In Bayern.
Schnelles gehen.
Ja, relativ schnelles gehen, aber eher anstrengende Strecken gehen.
Durch die Pampa gelatscht, genau.
Soll ich euch zeigen, wo ich gelaufen bin? Kann ich machen. Sekunde, zeige ich euch.
Spessart, Spuren, Wanderwege.
Ich bin heute gelaufen.
Alter, was ist mit der Seite los, man?
What the fuck?
Ich bin heute gelaufen.
Uff.
Hier.
Ich glaube das da.
Ich glaube das hier.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass es da halt relativ ordentlich
berghoch und runter geht.
Also man konnte das schon mal komplett knicken, was hier teilweise eingezeichnet wurde, weil du mit dem Auto überhaupt nicht hingegangen bist.
Also angefangen habe ich ungefähr, ich habe woanders geparkt, ich musste
in Lützel, ich habe irgendwo in Lützel geparkt.
Auf 230 Höhenmeter ungefähr und bin dann hochgelaufen auf
so zu 450.
Und die Runde hat ungefähr gedauert, so 1,40 würde ich sagen.
Die Namen von diesen Dörfern müsst ihr euch entwundern.
Hier gibt es Lützel, Linsengericht,
Huckelhaus oder so.
Es gibt hier wirklich Dorfnamen, das könnt ihr euch nicht ausdenken.
Ich bin da hingefahren, ja.
Ich fahre öfters in solche, ich habe so ein paar Ecken, wo ich gerne hinfahre.
Hat man beim Laufen nicht kurz keinen Bodenkontakt?
Also ich mache das nicht anhand olympischer Disziplin, also
ich achte weder darauf, ob ich Bodenkontakt habe, noch ob ich Bodenkontakt habe.
Also es ist durchaus möglich, dass man mal zwischenzeitlich keinen
Bodenkontakt hatte, aber wahrscheinlich hatte ich die meiste Zeit
über Bodenkontakt.
Affenhausen gibt es bei uns auch in der Nähe.
Affenhausen sind irgendwie ganz komisch.
So zumindest, wie gesagt, im Kreis gelaufen von irgendwie 230 Meter hoch
auf 450 Meter.
What the fuck?
Was war denn das? Du hast einen Dorf in der Nähe, das heißt pissen.
Ja besser als fucking.
So zumindest hier Höhenprofil, das war schon, also das war relativ anstrengend.
Vor allem, weil die
den Weg, der Weg hier runter ist richtig kacke.
Die haben festgestellt, die Runde wird zu lang mit den 0815 Casual Wanderer
und die wollten es nicht irgendwie hier außen rum machen, sondern hier.
Und ohne Scheiß, du musst hier quasi, du roffelst den Berg runter hier.
Also das ist wirklich, keine Ahnung, 20 Prozent Gefälle
mehr oder weniger durch die Hecke, den Berg runter.
Weiß ich nicht, ob die irgendwelche Bilder davon haben.
So zumindest, das bin ich heute gelaufen.
Eine Stunde 40, die schreiben mir ja irgendwas von wegen, dass es angeblich nur,
ich habe mich auch einmal verlaufen, die schreiben mir, dass angeblich plus 1,13
ist Schwachsinn. Also es ist viel, gut ich war auch ein bisschen im Dorf.
Es ist deutlich anstrengender als leicht, den Weg kannst du definitiv nie im Leben leicht laufen.
Weil da geht es wie gesagt teilweise 20 Prozent durch die Hecke, den Berg runter.
Und wer auch immer gedacht hat, dass es leicht ist.
Was warst du mal dort? Wo? Was ist denn dort? Kann ich das aufmachen?
Was hältst du von der Windows Diagnose Lücke? Meinst du Polymer?
Da zerstört jetzt Auto. Was hier? Wie kommst du da drauf?
Wohnst du da bei Strike oder was? Bombs, in Bombs.
Nein, in Bombs und in Eichstägen war ich noch nie.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo das ist. Keine Ahnung, das ist aber auch nicht bei mir in der Nähe.
Ähm, ich wohne ja hier.
Da, wo ist es denn? Ich wohne hier in der Ecke, ein bisschen weiter weg.
Ich muss eine andere Playlist, die Playlist nervt mich.
Du, du, du, du. Du, du, du, du, du, du.
Ja, also MS-DST, da hab ich tatsächlich ein Video zugemacht.
Chat, ich muss gleich mal in den Chat gucken, ich hab den Chat gar nicht durchgelesen.
Ich habe da ein Video zugemacht und zwar da, Virus ohne Anklinken.
Da hab ich mich ein bisschen dazu ausgelassen, erzählt.
Ja, es ist halt so ein typischer Windows-shit.
Also diese MS-DST Sache ist ja doppelt problematisch.
Es ist ja einmal die Seite gewesen von Word, wo der Sinn ist, dass Word aus dem Internet
irgendwelche Vorlagen runterladen kann, die HTML und gar Javascript enthalten, das einfach
so ausgeführt wird, dass man dann wiederum nutzen kann, um lokale Windows-Programme auszuführen
ist ja an sich schon äußerst pepega, also warum auch immer Word überhaupt diese total
dämliche Funktion drin hat, ich weiß es nicht, und das nächste Problem ist MS-DST, also
dass du das dazu auch überreden kannst, mit den passenden Parametern PowerShell Sachen
zu starten, ohne dass es überhaupt angezeigt wird.
Also, es ist hängen gebliebener Microsoft-Shit wieder, irgendjemand hat geschrieben, hörst
du beim Laufen Musik meistens nicht, nee, irgendjemand hat geschrieben, dass ich ihm
empfohlen werde auf Twitch, ich hab es nur ganz kurz gesehen, ich weiß nicht wo es ist,
aber schön, dass du den Weg hergefunden hast, möglich, dass ich ByteStrike auch letztens
mal irgendwo gesehen hab, ich weiß nicht mehr wo, aber ich spiele mir auch ein, ich hab
letztens, ich war in irgendeinem Technik-Channel und ich hab glaub ich ByteStrike gesehen,
der da Zeug rumgespammt hat, ich hab mich aber nicht zu erkennen gegeben, Chainlaw hab
ich auch schon öfters gesehen in anderen Channels Zeug rumspammen, aber dem wundert
mich das auch nicht, bestimmt beim Pool-Stream wahrscheinlich, ja, welche Grafiker hast du
aktuell, ich hab eine 1080Ti, immer noch, ich will mir seit Jahren schon einen neuen
Rechner kaufen, ich warte jetzt auf die neue Nvidia-Generation und mal gucken wie es mit
neuen CPUs aussieht, da kaufe ich mir endlich wieder mal einen neuen Rechner, es wird langsam
Zeit.
Wo ist denn irgendjemand, irgendjemand hat auch geschrieben, ah hier, genau Felix, moin,
ich kriege ein Video von dir vorgeschlagen, ich klicke zufällig auf dein Twitch, du bist
noch live, tja, ich bin aber erst seit 20 Minuten oder so live, hast du ein gutes Timing
erwischt, machen wir da einen PC-Bild-Stream vielleicht, das ist gar keine schlechte Idee,
Zeit für AMD, letztes Jahr hätte ich mir einen AMD gekauft, letztes Jahr, ich hab ja
schon immer, ich hab ja schon im Stream ein paar Sachen zusammengestellt, ich wollte mir
eigentlich einen, boah was war das, 5900X glaube ich kaufen, aber ich weiß nicht, kommt
drauf an, es kommt drauf an, es kommt drauf an, was denn dann nächstes Jahr, wenn es
neue Grafiken gibt, was denn dann für CPUs angesagt sind, bzw. was denn für CPUs sich
lohnen, preisleistungstechnisch, kann sein, dass ich bei ihm geguckt habe, ja, ich bin
mal gespannt, so jetzt switchen wir mal kurz rüber, gucken ob hier alles geupdatet ist,
jo, jo, alles geupdatet, hatte ich das ja auch schon gesagt, check for updates, gut,
ich muss mal kurz gucken, wie es mit kernel-updates aussieht, und dann rebooten wir und dann legen
wir los, was hab ich installiert, 515, warum hab ich denn so einen uralt kernel installiert,
ah weil der LTS ist, gut, yes, excellent, war der Gelegenheit einmal rebooten, dann geht's
los, was, Felix schreibt mir wurde dein Video über deine mündliche Prüfung vorgeschlagen,
ist das die game one musik, nein das ist irgendeine mario, doki doki panik ist das ja eigentlich
irgendeine mario 2 musik, ich weiß nicht vielleicht verwende die game one auch, keine ahnung,
was bedeutet LTS, genau, long term support, ist jetzt nicht in dem fall wirklich relevant,
aber man, funktioniert, ich muss euch sagen, ich hatte noch nie schlechte erfahrungen mit
nem kernel-update, warum hab ich den package jason bitteschön in meinem heimatverzeichnis,
was machten die her, auch noch express, was macht die denn da, die schmeißen wir mal weg,
ich weiß nicht was die da macht, das geflame, ja ich hoffe wir müssen uns nicht so sehr
mit c++ auseinandersetzen, also passt, so, reboot, nee, nee, moment, ich hab doch schon
rebooted gerade, warum soll ich noch mal rebooten, lul, repos, monarch, cpp und starten, alles
klar, ja am-af ist bei mir nicht so schlimm, weil ich kanns dir zeigen, ich hab am alias
zu trash, und trash ist quasi die rm-variante, etwas, etwas secure, dass du die sachen wieder
restauren kannst, wenn du willst, ja, gut, dann gucken wir uns das ganze mal an, also
ich zeige euch mal schnell wo wir stehen geblieben sind, und zwar auf dieser seite, ja was jetzt,
ist die seite nicht verfügbar oder doch, die seite ist nicht verfügbar, aber ist doch
verfügbar, what, das kommt bestimmt aus dem cache, die kann überhaupt nicht verfügbar
sein, weil ich hab nix gestartet was verfügbar ist, restart visual studio code, ok mach ich,
was hattest du eigentlich, oder jemand hier im chat, ist mal so, dass eine go datei von
windows defender ist realer erkannt, bei mir war es so, ähm, ich muss dir ehrlich sagen,
ich verwende so gut wie keine go sachen auf windows, weil ich mach alles in meiner linux
vm, da mach ich mir keine großartigen gedanken über irgendwelche vieren, so wo sind wir
hier stehen geblieben, monarch, cpp, www root, node, node.js mussten wir ausführen, glaub
das funktioniert, gell, ja, ok passt, also ich zeige euch nochmal ganz schnell wo wir
stehen geblieben waren, für alle die es letztes mal nicht mitbekommen haben, also wir haben
uns ffmpeg geschnappt, und haben ffmpeg nach webassembly kompiliert, das haben wir gemacht
mit einem docker container, wo ich in irgendeinem blog post ordentliche ffmpeg compiler settings
gefunden habe, so, also wir haben ffmpeg, achso, wir haben es ein bisschen erneuert
versus diesen blog post, also sprich, wir haben die neuste ffmpeg version und die neuste,
das neuste stk dafür, dann haben wir das ganze kompiliert, und dann haben wir ein c++ program
gebastelt mit mscripten, das ist eine c++ zu webassembly compiler, den kann man so nennen,
man übersetzt c++ in webassembly, das bedeutet, man kann damit c++ im browser ausführen,
so und was jetzt passiert, wenn ich hier ein video file hoch lade, ist folgendes, ich hab
mein testvideo genommen, also wenn ich mein video file hoch lade, so, dann passiert folgendes,
also der spielt das übrigens viel zu schnell ab, weil er so schnell abspielt, wie er irgendwie
kann, dann wird das video decoded im browser mit ffmpeg, also sprich, der bekommt das video
file und dann gehts hier weiter in diesem c++ teil, der guckt, welche video codec verwendet
der ganze kram, dann decoded das multithreaded mit 4 kern, dann legt der decoder an und im
endeffekt, das interessante, was passiert ist hier, der holt sich einen neuen frame aus
dem video, schickt den zum decoder, und der decoder decoded das, ich bekomme den frame
quasi als entkomprimierte bilddatei, und die schick ich dann hiermit zurück an javascript,
so, die funktion ist hier, und dort render ich die unkomprimierte bilddatei dann in browser
rein, und das ist ziemlich anstrengend für den browser, was man hier oben auch sieht,
ich mach grad noch mal eine sache, guck mal, wir können grad mal multithreading noch ein
bisschen hoch drehen, das hier seht, das ding ist ganz schön ausgelastet, achja, und was
der multithreaded macht, ist hier folgendermaßen, der kann, also ffmpeg kann das standardmäßig,
du kannst sagen, der decoder soll multithreaded, aber in dem fall hier mit 4 kern, man kann
auch sagen 0, dann nimmt er so viel wie geht, und man muss ihm auch gar nicht sagen, wie
er das machen soll, ja, ich wollt eigentlich nur das terminal größer machen, aber ok,
das geht nicht, hat man das letzte mal hier unten im terminal ausgeführt oder nicht,
ja mit rust geht schlecht mit ffmpeg, ich hab's probiert, das war ein bisschen eklig,
ich hätte auch c++ verwendet, aber, oh ich hab irgendwas kaputt gemacht, also aus irgendwelchen
Gründen grad proben, ach ok geht wieder, so und was wollt ich jetzt eigentlich zeigen,
ich wollte das mit dem multithreading noch mal anders machen, make, so jetzt wird das
neu kompiliert, das kompilieren dauert ein bisschen, ach ja ich hab auch noch eine sache
gemacht Leute, wir haben das ganze jetzt mit c++ 23 features, ich wollt einfach gucken
ob's funktioniert, neuste c++ shit haben wir, so und jetzt decode ich das ganze mal hier
super hardcore multithreaded 1080p 60 fps, guckt's euch an 1080p 60 fps läuft ohne probleme
bei 72% cpu last, also ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen wie krass die performance eigentlich
ist von dieser ganzen webassembly geschichte, der decoded über die cpu, über die cpu quasi
manuell über ffmpeg, decoded der im browser 1080p 60 fps video und ist schneller da drinne
als das video eigentlich läuft, kann das hardware acceleration, ffmpeg kann hardware acceleration,
aber was im ffmpeg kann's nicht, weil du keinen zugriff auf die grafikkarte hast, was du machen
kannst ist mit webgl rendern, wir rendern ja mit webgl die ausgabe, das ist richtig mega
hyper schnell, achja ich kanns euch mal zeigen, also der ist ziemlich gut ausgelastet gerade,
guckt mal, also der macht quasi alle meine cpus dicht, also der ist ganz schön ausgelastet
hier, poggers, so machen wir das mal weg, so und was ich mir überlegt hab was wir heute
probieren, das ist ja nur ein, das war ja das letzte mal nur ein kleiner test um zu gucken
wie es prinzipiell funktioniert und es gibt jetzt so ein paar sachen, also da kommt wahrscheinlich
nie was sinnvolles raus was man in irgendeiner anwendung benutzen kann, das ist jetzt einfach
zum ausprobieren und so den anwendungsfall den ich mir konstruiert habe ist, wie wäre
es denn wenn der browser was abspielen kann an video was browser normalerweise nicht abspielen
können und was browser normalerweise nicht abspielen können ist zb mpeg 2, mpeg 2 wird
gerne benutzt für sd fernsehaufnahmen zb, wenn man angenommen, also zb ihr habt nen
streaming server und ihr wollt dort drüber im browser was abspielen, bei den meisten
sachen ist es kein problem, die meisten sachen heutzutage sind h264, das kann der browser
nicht abspielen, einmal angenommen ihr habt irgendwelche formate, es muss ja nicht mehr
mpeg 2 sein, mal angenommen ihr habt irgendwelche formate, die der browser nicht abspielen
kann, dann gibt es die möglichkeit ihr transcodeet das auf serverseite, das heißt ihr braucht
ja nen fetten server oder ihr transcodeet das auf kleinseite, was im browser bedeutet
und das machen wir hier, ich bin mal gespannt ob wir das gebacken kriegen, also ich hab mir
überlegt wir machen halt folgendes, wir versuchen mal was anderes abzuspielen als h264 und
wir versuchen den ganzen krempel mal zu streamen, weil aktuell ist es so, ich muss die ganze
datei hochladen, ich lade die datei hoch hier seht ihr hier drüber, lade ich die datei
hoch und jetzt flutschte aber jetzt will er es aber wissen, wollen wir mal 4k machen
Leute, soll ich mal just for fun 4k 60 fps machen, eine sekunde oder zwei sekunden und
gucken ob er das abspielen kann, mal gucken ob das funktioniert ok, also nur ob das wenn
er von der performance funktioniert, also ich mein das ist nicht dafür gedacht, ganz
ehrlich 4k 60 fps kannst du decoden mit hardware acceleration im browser, aber über webassembly
im browser ist es unsinnig, es ist eigentlich total unsinnig, aber wir probieren es mal
aus, also nehmen wir mal hier die 20 sekunden out, so und jetzt, boah ffmpeg upscale, weiß
du aus dem kopf nicht wie das funktioniert, upscaling ja, hier vfscale, flex, flex, landkotz,
ok 60, aber nicht 1080p, was ist denn 4k für eine auflösung überhaupt, was ist denn 4k
für eine auflösung, was ist, das da 3048x2060, da war auch das beispiel für 4k, wo ember,
ne das eher nicht, ach was soll ich suchen ember 60 fps, nein ich will keine, ich will
keine weep, das hier auf, hier auf dem wikipedia oder was, ich hab keine ahnung, ach auf der
ffmpeg seite, ach so du meinst für das upscaling, ich dachte das ist irgendein, ja gut, oh der
macht was anderes, warum ist das denn jetzt, ja leute was ist denn jetzt das richtige 4k,
1000 eindings oder, oder das, massive 4k ist das hier, kannst du bitte meine dicke katze
nerds grüßen, klar mach ich, sekunde wo hab ich das bild von chigo, ach ich find's
ein bisschen, ja ich grüße deine dicke katze nerds, pepo fett, 1000 eindings ist richtig,
ok sehste ppega seite, also da lassen wir uns mal kurz transcodeen, oh, oh das ist pepo
slow, das ist pepo hyper slow, na gut ich encode hier auch neu und also meine videos
rendere ich in 1440p, das geht halbwegs mit der geschwindigkeit aber 4k upscaling ist
schon wirklich sehr slow, aber das macht nix, das video ist plus 10 sekunden lang, nee 20
sekunden, 20 sekunden lang, na dann müssen wir jetzt durch, leute noch 10, noch 10 sekunden
pepo slow, die cpu geht aber auch jetzt schon ganz schön ab, chat eure meinung, kann es
der browser abspielen oder nicht, meine persönliche meinung ist es klappt nicht, der ist am limit
mit 1080p 60, der kriegt 4k 60 im leben nicht hin, also nur mit halt, er kriegt das hin
mit abspielen aber er ist halt langsamer als die 60 fps, 60 fps pro sekunde cringe, es
gibt leute die sagen das, die sagen 60 fps pro sekunde, das sind auch die leute die sagen
der verbrauch ist 50 watt pro sekunde, pro stunde, so, gucken wir mal, 4k 60, naja also
mal ganz im ernst, ich mein das ist definitiv keine 60 fps, die cpu ist komplett am anschlag,
aber für das, dass das null hardware accelerated ist, das ist ffmpeg im browser, also transpiled,
transcoded wie auch immer im browser, ist das echt nicht schlecht, in einer vm wohlgemerkt
noch wobei das egal ist für die cpu leistung, vms haben quasi keinen nennenswerten einfluss
auf cpu performance, ach guck mal, lilycali, bewerbungsgespräche dann gestern, poggers,
die waren faszinierend was ich in meinem alter schon alles gemacht habe, mega nice, pog,
und was haben sie gesagt, also als was warst du noch mal da, war das fahrinformatiker systemintegration
oder warst du der der praktikum, ja fisi, fisi, ja und was haben sie gesagt, nehmen
sie dich, oder haben sie gesagt, eben sie müssen erst noch mal abwarten oder was kam
raus, melden sie sich, das ist übrigens nix schlimmes, das ist ja ein film immer so nach
dem motto wir melden uns gleich, man wird nicht genommen, also ganz im ernst, ich habs
noch nie erlebt, dass man irgendwo zum vorstellungsgespräch war und der typ instant nach dem
vorstellungsgespräch gesagt hat, ja hier unterschreiben sie direkt, also ich mein die haben vielleicht
nicht massig bewerber, vielleicht schon ein paar andere, also ein tach später, also aber
wenn sie dich haben wollen, aber wenn sie, das hab echt, also ich hab das noch nie erlebt,
wenn sie dich haben wollen ging das aber immer relativ schnell, also eins, zwei, drei tage
später, wenn die da irgendwie erst wochen für brauchen dann eher nicht, also es ging
bei mir immer relativ schnell wenn sie wollten, ja stimmt heute gehts nicht, also das hatte
ich echt noch nicht, dass einer direkt gesagt hat unterschreiben sie gleich, ja jetzt mach
ihm hier mal keine Angst, also wenn das gut gelaufen ist und die da von C plus ist C plus
plus hart, C plus plus ist undurchsichtig und beschissen, mir fällt da kein anderes
Wort für, C plus plus ist die beschissenste programmiersprache die es gibt, da kanns selbst
kobold ist besser auf seine art, ok also 4k kriegen wir nicht hin, gut jetzt machen wir
mal was sinnvolles leute, wir haben jetzt oft genug videos abgespielt, also ich hab mir überlegt
wir versuchen jetzt mal was abzuspielen was der browser nicht kann und wir versuchen das
zu streamen, chat sagt mir mal mit was wir anfangen wollen, also nur mal zur erklärung,
also nur mal zur erklärung, aktuell ist es ja so ich hab hier dieses input element darüber
lade ich das video hoch und das video nachdem es hochgeladen ist übergebe ich dann an ffmpeg
das passiert hier an der stelle, guck da exakt an dieser stelle passiert das, er sagt ffmpeg
bearbeite mal die datei die unter slashwork mit dem filenamen legt, mach nach jedem schleifen
millisekunden sleep dass der browser nicht einfriert und ja dann machen wir, also an
der stelle passiert das, so und wenn man die datei immer erst hochladen muss ist blöd
ich würde gerne die datei von irgendwoher streamen, das ist das eine was ich gerne ausprobieren
würde die datei zu streamen und das andere ist ich würde gerne ausprobieren was abzuspielen
was der browser standardmäßig nicht kann, c sharp, c sharp ist a much better language
than c++, but sometimes you need c++, i like c sharp its my favorite language and i really
dont like c++, was ich t++ brauche ganz einfach mit ffmpeg interop, weil ffmpeg sich wunderbar
von c++ ansprechen lässt und sich auch easy das ganze übersetzen lässt in webassembly,
was hältst du von java geht auch unsere java leute auf der arbeit stehen hauptsächlich
auf kotlin, aber die dürfen damit nix machen aber ich mag c sharp deutlich mehr, die updates
von microsoft sind auch sinnvoll was die jedes jahr machen
i would do this project in c sharp, but this time we need c++ to interface with ffmpeg
and cross compile it to webassembly to run in the browser, so you can play videos in formats
the browser normally cannot play, so, yes its just a test, it will never be a finished
application, also leute was wollen wir als erstes machen, also wir haben jetzt zur auswahl
wir können versuchen zu streamen, also wie gesagt aktuell kriegen wir das video ja immer
nur so rein, wir können versuchen zu streamen oder wir können versuchen erstmal ein anderes
videoformat abzuspielen, ich würde sagen wir versuchen erstmal ein anderes videoformat
abzuspielen oder, also wir nehmen mal irgendwas, welche auflösung ist ein PAL, wir machen
mal was realistisches, also ich nehme jetzt mal mein video, nehmen wir mal hier das da
1080p, was ist ein PAL für eine auflösung, PAL resolution, i geht alter 768x506, was ist
das für eine beschissene auflösung, und 50 fps oder, was hat er, 30, 50 hat es da
noch, was hat ein PAL für eine, für eine, 850 interlaced, leute soll ich mir zum testen
lieber ein video von meinem, von meinem tv header drunter laden, ich hab gestern extra
zum testen, 15 sekunden, 15 sekunden, aber interlacing da hab ich ja gar keinen bock
drauf, ok, also, wir probieren es jetzt erstmal nochmal, also ffmpeg, haben wir irgendwie
20 sekunden, ne wie war das, scale, 720 scale, runter auf, was war das jetzt, ah ne das ist
ja meine güde alter, 1080, scale, was 7, 768x506, wer hat sich denn diese pepega, ähm, auflösung
ausgedacht man, so leute was war das, rate, für die fps, ne 30 oder, wir bleiben bei
30, so nicht mp4, ähm, wie mein es, wie mein ts, und wie kriegen wir das jetzt, moment,
ok, ffmpeg, mpeg 2 video, wie kriegen wir das denn, das hat alles hand und fuß mit
der auflösung, ja das war wahrscheinlich passend zur lochmaske im alten crt, lochmaske
ist ja auch absolut paintschampiges ding, copy, alter, hier, das brauch ich, ok, ich
hoffe das funktioniert jetzt, ffmpeg, es ist nicht rate, es ist minus r, how many language
do you know, puh, i know c sharp, i know a bit c++, i know ruby, bash, a little bit python,
medium level goleng, bit of rust, was hab ich vergessen leute, hatte ich txt auf dem
desktop, echt, wo, die hatte ich nicht auf dem desktop, die hatte ich nicht in irgendeinem
game, kooboll, yes we made one kooboll stream two years ago, so i'm kooboll expert, also,
so leute, jetzt muss ich mich konzentrainieren, so wir haben jetzt ein video hier am start
und zwar haben wir denn, das ist ja falsch wie ich das genannt habe, das ist kompletter
Blödsinn, das sind nicht 20 Säcke, das sind 20 Säcke, 30 TS, FF Probe, so guckt, es ist
MPEG 2 Video. So, wie kriegen wir den Cramp? Alter, spuky, spuky Musik wieder hier. Kurz überspringen.
Du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, viel besser. Ja, es geht nicht anders, ich muss C++ kalfen,
ich muss, dankeschön für den Zap, ich muss C++ verwenden. Ich will FF MPEG im Browser laufen
lassen und FF MPEG im Browser. Leute, wir machen bei der Gelegenheit mal eine Sache kurz. Mach mal
kurz, ich mach mal kurz einen Commit. Get, Commit, PEC V. Beste, beste Commit Message,
immer, immer sowas einchecken an Commit Messages. So. Is Rust hard to reverse? I don't know. Never
tried. So. Also. Wie kriegen wir das dem jetzt beigebracht, dass wir jetzt eine andere Datei
haben? Was passiert denn, wenn ich versuche einfach diese Datei abzuspielen? Das wird
wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren, gehe ich mal von aus. Ich vermute, wir müssen FF MPEG
neu kompilieren mit den passenden, passenden Unterstützungen. So, wo sind wir denn hier?
PAL. Okay, PAL funktioniert nicht. Also, wie kriegen wir, wie kriegen wir eine TS-Datei
geöffnet? Zeig mal her. Das müssen wir hier machen. Also, file.ts, das passt an der Stelle
schon mal. Also, bis hierhin sollte das alles klappen. So, find decoder. Das passt schon
mal nicht, weil wir sagen open. So, ich muss gucken, ob wir. Leute, wisst ihr, was wir
verhalten können? Pass mal auf, ich zeige euch mal eines, eines der wenigen C++ Features,
die ganz gut sind. Und auch, auch nur, weil. Ja, guck mal. Auch nur, weil sie das eins
zu eins von Python geklaut haben. Wie Format gibt es nicht? Ah, ich muss mein Visual Studio
umstellen, wahrscheinlich. C++. Ah, wo stellt man den C++ Standard um? C++ Standard. Wo
ist er? Hier. C++ 20. Ne, wir haben, wir haben C++ 23, Alter. Massive. Äh. Warum geht
das nicht? Warum nutzt du kein C line? Das ist eine gute Frage, keine Ahnung. Im Make
File ist es schon eingestellt. Hä? Moment. Wo ist denn das Problem? Ich meine, er kann
das übersetzen. Es scheint schon mal zu geben. Also ich will euch eigentlich jetzt mal, jetzt
wollte ich euch mal eine Sache. Ne, das macht in dem Fall keinen Unterschied. Ich wollte
euch mal eine sinnvolle Sache an C++ zeigen und jetzt geht's wieder. Include Format.
Warum? Wo ist das Problem? Wo ist das Problem? Warum erkennt er das nicht? Das ist doch bestimmt
irgendein Visual Studio Shit, der nicht funktioniert. Guck hier, das soll ich machen. Include Format.
So, und dann kann ich nämlich sowas hier machen. Guck mal. Dann kann ich, dann kann ich Python
Style formatieren. Gucken, ob das funktioniert. Make. Funktioniert, gar kein Problem. Warum
kann es mein, warum checkt es mein Browser nicht? Äh, nicht mein Browser, warum checkt
es Visual Studio nicht? Hat kein Bock. Hat kein Bock. Ich mach das einfach mal zu und
wieder auf, dann geht's wahrscheinlich. Null. FFmpeg, nice. FFmpeg, Massive Pog. Alter,
Visual Studio, wo ist dein Problem? Was ist, was ist das Problem? Das ist, das ist, guck
dir mal Leute. Es ist C++ Standard und du Includes ein C++ Standard header und er sagt, es gibt's
nicht. Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn. Hat Visual Studio hier irgendwelche temporären
Dinger? Nö. Keine Ahnung. Ich hab keine Ahnung, warum man es nicht hier findet. Ich meine,
es funktioniert ja offensichtlich. Es, es funktioniert ja offensichtlich. Guckt. Bam.
Achtung. Keck weh. Es funktioniert. Beim Bilden ist dann alles in Ordnung. Ja, schön, aber
ich will ja die Autovervollständigung dafür haben. Ah, das, jetzt. Ja, was mach ich jetzt,
dass es C++ checkt? Weißt was? Ich, wir machen, wir machen mal Folgendes. Das ist keine Knue
Extension. Das ist C++ Standard. Guck. Mal gucken, ob das, mal gucken, ob das mehr bringt.
Oh, ich kack noob. Jetzt hab ich, jetzt hab ich den Gramm gelöscht, den ich, den ich
brauch. Ich, ich dreh bei C++. Also Leute, mal ohne Scheiße. Header-Dateien, Header-Dateien
sind wirklich der allergrößte Abfuck, den es gibt. Keckl. Ähm, warte mal, wo gab's
denn diesen Gramm jetzt? Pac-Man? Hier. Include. Muss es wieder hinzufügen. Include. Boi,
Schwamm, Alter. Keckl. Nächster Keckl. Das brauchen wir wieder. Ich will meine Funktion
dahinschreiben, wie ich das in jeder normalen, halbwegs modernen, gescheiten Programmiersprache
mache. Dass sich der Gramm dafür, für mich darum kümmert. Ich mein, in jeder anderen
Programmiersprache brauchst du keine Header-Files. Hier. Nee, das ist, weil ich die Einstellungen
gelöscht habe. Eben hatte ich es woanders. Warum findet er das nicht? Das muss er finden.
Das liegt da drunter. Hä? Ah. Hätte ich so machen müssen?
Aber warum checkt er, dass es Format nicht gibt? Das muss er doch checken. Ich hab keine
Ahnung, was der für Schmerzen hat, Alter. Navigier mal in die Standardlib. Warum? Warum
kann der Scheiß nicht einfach funktionieren wie in normalen Ideen und normalen Programmiersprachen?
Okay, keine Ahnung, wie man das zu laufen. Ist auch wurscht. Ich mein, es geht auch ohne,
aber warum geht das nicht? Das hat zwar nichts mit dem zu tun, was wir jetzt machen wollen,
aber ich krieg schon wieder Anfälle bei diesem Rotz. Wer hat sich diese Sprache ausgedacht?
Ich will diesen Header nicht erzählen. Ich will einfach, dass du sagst, ja, ich weiß,
ich verwende C++ Standard und Format ist C++ Standard. Also gibt es das in dieser Version?
Da steht seit 2000. Seit 20 Standard. Und wenn ich 20 Standard auswähle, erwarte ich,
dass das auch einfach da ist, wenn ich das hier drin auswähle. Was ist das für ein
Modus? Okay, was? Select Configuration, Linux, ja, was sonst? Zilang, ja, schön. Wie kriege
ich das dem beigebracht, dass er jetzt, dass er das checkt? Linux, soll ich GCC auswählen?
Soll ich GCC, ich kann auch GCC auswählen. Das ist ja hier GCC x86. What the fuck? GCC
ist auch egal. Es juckt dir nicht, es ist dir vollkommen egal. Es ist aber doch auch
egal, ob ich GCC oder sonst was auswähle. Was hatte ich in Standardmäßig? Das da?
Ich sehe das, das ist Standardlib. Da hat nichts im Fahrt zu sein. So eine Bullshit-Sprache,
aber wer sich diesen Dreck ausgedacht hat? Guckt es euch an, diese elendliche Drecksprache.
Es funktioniert nicht mal so einfache Sachen, wie man included etwas, was im Standard drin
ist und die IDE checkt. Okay, das ist wahrscheinlich ein Problem von der C++-Extension, aber trotzdem,
reine Fresse, das ist so schlecht alles. Advanced Settings. Okay, ich werde, wie ist Code? Include
Format. Ich weiß ja nicht, wann man sich suchen soll überhaupt hier. Andere C++-Extension gibt's
nicht. Wie ist Code? So einfachen Krempel musst du es doch auch hinkriegen. Ich meine,
wir brauchen das nicht. Wir brauchen das nicht wirklich. Der Witz ist, es funktioniert ja.
Oh, Massive. Die Leute googeln. Ist doch was ganz anderes. Nein, da muss nichts included,
das ist Standard-Library seit C++ 20. Poggers Soundtrack. Ich hasse diese Sprache, so schlecht
alles. Okay, wisst ihr, was wir machen? Wir gehen jetzt in die Extensions. Pass mal auf,
Poggers. 5-Hat. 5-Hat. C++-Extension? Nee. Ist das das, was ich schon installiert habe?
Uninstall. Uninstall C++. Die Extension? Nein, die Extension kann mehr. Uninstall. Was? Ah,
die Plattform war auch Dependeter dran. Kann man hier den Standard irgendwie einstellen?
Ich meine. Come on. Guck doch mal, was für ein Ding. User include C++ 21, was auch immer.
Das ist aber doch egal, was das lokal ist. Der soll einfach so tun, als gäbe es das.
Ist 12, ist 12, 21, aber das ist doch alles in Ordnung, oder? Warum gibt es hier kein Format?
Wo ist das Problem? Wie kann sowas eigentlich so beschissen gemacht sein? Was muss ich jetzt
installieren, dass ich den Kram habe? Ich meine, ernsthaft? Was muss ich installieren dafür? Ich
habe doch allen möglichen Shit drauf, oder? Ich habe GCC drauf, ich habe Kram drauf.
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass das was mit meinem lokalen System Krams
zu tun hat. Und vor allem, warum habe ich da kein Format? Müsste ich da ein Format haben?
Was auch immer das da ist. Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, ob das hier GCC-Headers sind. Wobei
Headers haben ja mit dem Compiler nichts zu tun. Ich habe keinen Schimmer. Mein Gott,
ist das alles immer rückständiger Shit. Jede Sprache der letzten 35 Jahre kriegt das hin,
aber C++ kriegt es nicht hin. Es ist unglaublich, Alter. Es ist unglaublich. Ich meine klar,
das liegt daran, weil ich keine Ahnung davon habe. Wahrscheinlich, wenn man es weiß,
ist es super easy. Aber es kann doch nicht sein. Warum sieht meine Shell hier so beschissen aus,
auf einmal? Also ich meine, ich habe den Standard geändert auf 2000 noch etwas. Und das ist
irgendein Wishill Studio Ding, dass das nicht funktioniert, weil ich habe ihm explizit gesagt,
ich benutze C++ Standard 23. Ich kann ja hier irgendwie 20 oder so sagen. Ist egal. Nö,
beim Kompilieren gibt es keinen Error. Das funktioniert, aber Kompilieren tun wir auch
mit dem Docker-Container mit dem WebAssembly-Cross-Compile-Ding. So. Nein, Rust-Wasm hat nicht funktioniert,
weil wir einfach MPEG-Bindings nicht getaugt haben. Da ist ein Punkt. Ah, dahinter. Nein,
das ist Standard Library. Ich wollte gerade sagen, geht es jetzt oder was? Ich habe schon
mehrfach neu gestartet. Das interessiert einfach nicht. Was muss ich tun, dass diese
Header auf WIT gefunden geht? Was muss ich da machen? Ich habe keine Ahnung, Alter. Cannot
find format. Not found. Okay, okay. Pass auf, krasses C++-Debugging. Compiler-Support,
kann ich überhaupt auswählen, was? Ich meine, ich verwende den Compiler im Docker-Container.
Es geht mir ja nur um die IDE, nur was die mir anzeigt. Ich kann ja sonst was unterschieben.
Compiler-Pass. Soll ich GCC? Okay,++. Viel besser. Nope. Okay, GCC. Nope. G++. Visual Studio
Code Up to Date, ja. Die Extensions auch. Okay, das hat anscheinend keine Einstellungen,
keine... Das ist schonmal egal. Windows, Windows. Ja, eindeutig Windows. Windows haben wir.
Das ist eben auch egal. Nach der Pass-Änderung... Ernsthaft? Neustarten? Aber der IntelliSense-Mode
ist doch eigentlich das, was mich interessiert, nicht der Compiler-Fahrt. Dankeschön, Max
105. Okay, das heißt, ich schalte das jetzt hier um auf GCC und jetzt starte ich neu.
Das ist so lächerlich, diese Drecksprache, Alter. Äh. Okay, ich schalte jetzt auf GCC
um mit. Ich mein, okay, pass mal auf, wir sagen jetzt C++17, easy. Dann geht's. Der
Roverflow hat Poggers gegoogelt. Okay, Achtung. Okay. Ey, das ist von 2020. Es ist aber doch
auch egal. Das ist für das IntelliSense doch wurscht, ob das der... Was da drunter? Ja.
Das kenn ich. Ich hab keine Ahnung, wo die Datei liegt. Sieh Compiler-Support. Der Supporter
sich kompiliert das doch und es funktioniert. Die können das. Das geht, das geht ja alles.
Das ist reine, reine Whistle Studio Geschichte, Whistle Studio Code Geschichte, dass der Krempel
nicht funktioniert. Ich weiß wirklich nicht, was ich da einstellen soll. Die Idee kriegt
ich hin, genau. Sackerscheiß, Alter. Das regt mich auf so was. Das regt mich einfach
auf, dass solche Basics-Sachen nicht funktionieren. Warum ich nicht wechsle? Weil wir eine Mischung
aus HTML und C++ machen müssen. Ich mein, was ich machen kann, ist ohne Scheiß. Wenn
die Datei hier öffnen. Ja, nicht Rust, Open. Repos, Monarch, Cpp. Ähm, warte mal, Source?
Das scheint einfach zu funktionieren jetzt, oder? Na gut, da will ich nichts sagen. Das
geht einfach, ordentliche IDE. Schon funktioniert's. Gut, nice. JetBrains, POG, Standard Thread,
come on. Oh Gott, jetzt hab ich ja wieder keine Keybindings da drin konfiguriert. Echt
so ein Drecks-Sprache, Alter. Warum checkt ihr das das nicht? Zumindest, was ich euch
zeigen wollte, die haben jetzt in C++ eine halbwegs ordentliche Geschichte, wie man Text
formatieren kann. Das haben die schlicht und ergreifend einfach von Python geklaut und
sieht ein bisschen aus wie Template Strings in C-Sharp. Ja, ich ignorier das und mach weiter.
Ich will das hier alles zusammen in einem Fenster haben, sonst blick ich dann immer
durch. Boah, Anfälle bei sowas. So, alles klar. Guck mal, eine Sache noch. Kann man
die Extension hier irgendwie... Zum Updaten gab's hier auch nix, gell? Wie checkt man
Extensions auf Updates überhaupt hier? Aha. Kann man das jetzt hier überschreiben? Das
ist doch was anderes als das, was ich vorhin angeklickt hab, oder?
Oh Gott! Oh Gott, bitte nein! Nein! Nein! NOOOOO!
Alter, ich raste aus bei so einem Krempel, wenn das nicht funktioniert. Ich drehe durch.
Warum gibt es überhaupt hier die Möglichkeit, es hier einzustellen? Was ist denn das eigentlich?
Warum gibt es hier sowas? Warum gibt es hier sowas? Was ist der Unterschied hier dazwischen?
Das ist die IntelliSense Configuration? Und das andere ist die Addon Configuration? Was
zum Teufel macht ihr da, Alter? Microsoft, please! Ah.
Oh Gott, ich raste aus bei so einem Krempel, wenn das nicht funktioniert. Was ist denn das
hier? Oh Gott, ich raste aus bei so einem Krempel, wenn das nicht funktioniert. Was
zum Teufel macht ihr da? Oh Gott, ich raste aus bei so einem Krempel, wenn das nicht funktioniert.
Was zum Teufel macht ihr da? Oh Gott, ich raste aus bei so einem Krempel, wenn das nicht funktioniert.
Das war's für heute.
So, der kackt, der kackt an der Stelle doch schon ab.
Hier, beim öffnen.
Der kann den, der erkennt das Input-Format nicht, gehe ich mal von aus.
Konnte man nicht Input, Probe oder sowas machen?
Probe, Input, Baffa?
Oh, da muss ich jetzt ein eigenes Ding zum Einlesen bauen für das Fall.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, da kann es einfach nicht öffnen.
Ich glaube, da kriegt es einfach nicht geöffnet.
Was ist das für eine bescheuerte Frage, Alter?
So.
Dann brauchen wir, dann müssen wir ein Format.
Find.
Was ist die Frage, Alter?
Okay, Konz Shortname für das Format.
Ist es MPEG TS?
Ich weiß gar nicht.
Das ist halt einfach MPEG Formats.
Formats.
So.
Ah, so, okay.
Ich glaube, MPEG TS ist das Richtige.
Ja, MPEG TS.
Können wir mal gucken, ob was das ist, was das sagt.
CD, Repos, Monarch, FF Probe.
Das ist ein MPEG TS mit MPEG 2 Video.
Okay, FF POC sollte ich das oben nennen.
Ja, so, also, Auto Format.
So, checkt es das?
Ja, Kekl, Dollar S Format.
So, wenn es das nämlich nicht kennt, dann muss ich FF MPEG neu kompilieren.
Name, dann muss ich FF MPEG neu kompilieren mit FF MPEG, mit, mit TS und MPEG 2 Videosupport
und Zeug.
Dann müssen wir noch mal zwei Minuten beim Kompilieren zugucken.
New Emote, was ist das denn für eins?
Guck mal, keine Chance.
Noch mal, if, kann man, kann man in C++ sowas machen?
Das müsste man auch tun, oder, dass es dann nicht abkackt.
Ah, eine Sache machen wir noch.
Ich gebe doch hier immer noch diesen Müll zurück.
Das brauchen wir alles gar nicht mehr zurückgeben.
Response is void.
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe, ich mache es jetzt nicht komplett kaputt.
Response is void und das brauchen wir dann nicht mehr hier.
Zack.
Ups, habe ich jetzt was zu viel gelöscht?
Ich habe irgendwo was zu viel gelöscht.
Was habe ich zu viel gelöscht?
Ah, das gehört da gar nicht dabei.
So.
Gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal, ob es prinzipiell noch läuft, was ich hier fabriziert habe.
Auf, kompilieren wir mal ein bisschen schneller.
Ok, es funktioniert alles noch, wenn es null ist, dann geht er gleich raus, alles klar.
Das ist Mario Galaxy Musik, ja.
So, Format, Doppelpunkt, Prozent S, Format, Name, gut, wir müssen es auf jeden Fall neu
kompilieren, weil der kennt MPEG-TS als Format nicht, das ist ziemlich pains-champ.
Kennt er TS, probieren wir mal kurz aus, kennt er einfach nur TS, ich weiß nicht, ob ich
die Endung angeben muss oder kompilieren, also ich würde jetzt einfach davon ausgehen,
dass ich das hier, was er hier als Input erkennt, da auch angeben muss, aber es ist einfach
MPEG, das ist alles nicht so logisch.
No Format, ok.
So, also schön, nice, neu kompilieren, Dogger-File, was sind wir, also was brauchen wir, die Muxer,
die Coder, die Coder braucht auf jeden Fall MPEG-2-Video, machen wir hier die Formate,
Leute wo muss ich jetzt hier MPEG-TS reinschreiben, da, compile, also Muxer brauche ich eigentlich
eh keine, weil ich ja gar nichts encode, muss ich hier MPEG-TS machen, ich brauche irgendein
Beispiel, ja, ok, kann man, ok, also das habe ich schon mal richtig gemacht, enable MPEG-MPEG-TS,
ok, Decoder, so, das müsste doch eigentlich reichen, wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe,
Build, bei C++, wenn er größere Sachen kompiliert, habe ich immer Schiss, dass er gleich abbricht,
so, also die Muxer-MOF, MKV könnten wir uns eigentlich auch sparen, MPEG-TS, so, MPEG-TS
und Video-Codec habe ich MPEG-2-Video drin, das sollte jetzt eigentlich funktionieren.
Was wird heute gemacht, wir basteln weiter an dem Video-Player, also diesem Mini-Video-Player,
der im Browser Videos abspielen kann, die der Browser normalerweise nicht supportet,
in dem er mit FFMPEG die Sachen decoded, im Browser, deswegen brauchen wir auch C++,
damit wir diesen ganzen Kram so übersetzen können, dass der Browser das ausführen kann,
was ziemlich MonkaS ist und ich kriege heute schon wirklich, ich kriege regelmäßig Anfälle,
wenn ich C++ verwende, das hat man schon gesehen, dieser ganze Header-Scheiß, man, dass es
überhaupt noch gibt, ich meine, die haben jetzt Modul-Support, was meint ihr, wann man
ein Modul wirklich ordentlich realistisch verwenden kann, das ganze kommt, ich weiß gar nicht,
ob jetzt schon kommt, mit 23, bis die Compiler, dass alle ordentlich supporten, vergehen eh
noch 50 Jahre und dann ist eh die gesamte C++-Welt noch, besteht noch aus Header.
Wieso kommt jede andere Sprache ohne Header aus?
Ja, das sollte man sich tatsächlich mal fragen, das ist genau die richtige Frage, wie kann
das eigentlich sein, es muss ja, muss ja wohl irgendwie möglich sein.
Ich hätte 5 Header-Files, ja, aber realistisch gesehen, was passiert bei anderen Programmiersprachen,
du hast irgendeinen File, da definierst du eine Klasse oder eine Funktion oder was auch
immer und dann stellst du das als Library und sonst was zur Verfügung und dann werden
halt dort Metadaten mit exportiert, also sprich, was enthält diese Libraries an Definition
und die kann ich dann verwenden und gut ist.
Das könnte C++ auch machen, machen sie jetzt ja, aber mal gucken, meine CPU ist ganz schön
ausgelastet.
Headers sind eh so richtig verkackt, du kannst in Header so gut wie alles inline schreiben,
also du brauchst eigentlich gar keine CPP oder CC-Files mehr, außer ganz spezielle
Dinger, die gehen nicht in Header-Files, ich glaube statische Variablen gehen nicht in
Header-Files, also statische Klassen-Dinger.
So wir haben FFmpeg neu kompiliert, das heißt im Endeffekt, wenn wir Glück haben, sollte
er zumindest das Format jetzt erkennen, wenn er das Format jetzt nicht erkennt, weiß ich
nicht, was ich eintragen soll.
Mit was hast du eigentlich der Linux emuliert, das ist Vmware Workstation, nö da ruckelt
gar nichts, da ruckelt nix hier, soll da ruckeln.
So, gucken wir mal, ob er jetzt das richtige Format erkennt, wie das geht einfach?
Das geht einfach, ich meine es hat eine scheiß Auflösung, weil, weil, weil, aber es geht
einfach.
Wollen wir mal gucken, wie das Video in VLC aussieht, VLC, PAL-TS, ja das Video sieht
so beschissen aus, Kegwayne, ich glaube wir machen es mal in etwas, kurz mal in ein bisschen
höhere Qualität, ja, ich hätte auch nicht gedacht, dass es einfach funktioniert, wo
ist mein FFmpeg, ja, wie mache ich bessere Bitrate, Bitrate, ok, FFmpeg, mpeg 2 Video,
das ist die höchste Qualität, ja, Bitrate, Target PAL-DVD, genau, oh, yes, overwrite,
blutscht, VLC, so sieht es jetzt besser aus, ja, Leute, ok, die Bitrate macht schon einiges
aus, die Bitrate macht schon ein bisschen was aus, ja, wir machen mal, wir machen mal
das andere Video, wir machen mal nicht 20, 30, wir nehmen das komplette 1080p, 60, wobei
wir können einfach das, habe ich nicht noch was anderes, Zack, wir nehmen einfach das
30 FPS, oder, das habe ich sonst nicht, guck mal, das geht mega schnell, das Video, das
Video ist 10 Minuten lang und er hat schon eine Minute durch, ja, dann lassen wir das
drop, achso, der drop plus, weil die FPS doppelt sind, was, nur vier Minuten, wie nur vier
Minuten, wait a minute, warum nur vier Minuten, ah, wahrscheinlich, play frame, das, ach,
keine Ahnung, ist egal, so, schauen wir mal, äh, hallo, Leute, das funktioniert einfach,
guckt euch an, das geht einfach, FFmpeg neu kompiliert und schon kommen Videos abspielen,
die der Browser normalerweise gar nicht kann und man muss sagen, also, Performanceprobleme
gibt es hier auch keine, das würde wahrscheinlich sogar auf dem Handy funktionieren jetzt, ziemlich,
ziemlich, Pog, Poggy, muss ich sagen, by the way, warum ist denn das so groß, ach, ich
noob, weil das hier auf, auf, ähm, ich muss mal kurz mein Canvas umstellen, Cacvice, Cacvice
hat die falsche Auflung, 768, ne, 76, 768 ist es ja, hier 768, ja, besser, guck mal,
es klappt einfach, das hätte ich jetzt wirklich nicht gedacht und performanstechnisch ist
es auch vollkommen ok, ok, chat, ich beantworte mal die Fragen, die es hier gibt, ne, ne,
ne, ne, ne, ne, das funktioniert anders, ähm, weiß jetzt gar nicht, wo die originale Frage
kam, nein, das FFmpeg läuft im Browser, also wenn ich dir jetzt die Webseite, also,
wenn ich das jetzt verfügt, wenn ich das hier jetzt hochladen würde, auf einen Webserver
und du würdest ein Video von dir hochladen in diesem Format, dann könnte er das abspielen,
was ziemlich Poggy ist, ehrlich gesagt, du kannst damit im Browser Videos abspielen,
die der Browser normalerweise gar nicht kann, das würde sogar in Github Pages laufen, ja,
das würde überall laufen, das ist statischer Content, der Wasmchamp, zetzt das sehr laut,
ich hab noch nix, noch nix geklärt, mal gucken, weiß ich nicht, Wayland ist in VM der Ultrasack,
Alter, wir haben das letztens ausprobiert, im Inner4M hat Wayland noch nicht mal automatisch
den Screen Refreshed, könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, der hat noch nicht mal den
Screen Refreshed, du musstest immer den Bildschirm wechseln, dass er den Screen Refreshed hat,
hast du pauschal gesehen, nein, kommt aber ein bisschen drauf an, ob es relevant ist,
also das normale Videoelement ist um ein vielfaches Performanter, ganz einfach, warum?
Weil der Browser das Video decoded und der Browser Zugriff auf Grafikkarten und alles
und Decoder und GPU und alles hat, also wenn du ein Video abspielst, was der Browser supportet
im Videoelement, da kannst du da theoretisch, keine Ahnung, 8K 120 FPS abspielen und das
funktioniert noch, warum, weil der irgendwie GPU Decoder und Quick Sync Decoder und Gedöns
verwendet.
Wenn dein Browser allerdings das Videoformat nicht unterstützt, hast du gelitten und mit
meiner Methode kann man alles abspielen, was FFmpeg kann und FFmpeg kann nahezu alles,
allerdings ist es halt von der Performance nicht so gut, das bedeutet im Endeffekt, wenn
du super High Res Content und FPS Content hast, in einem Format, was der Browser nicht kann,
dann wirst du es damit auch nicht in Echtzeit abspielen können, aber ist halt so, man muss
aber mal ehrlich gesagt sagen, die Performance ist wirklich gut davon, das hätte ich gar
nicht gedacht, man darf ja nicht vergessen, dass ein normales FFmpeg wahrscheinlich so
ein 8K 120 FPS Video oder so auch nicht decoded, ich kann es gerade nicht auf dem iPad testen.
Das machen wir alle mal, ich will das erstmal mit Streaming ausprobieren, ich mein guck
mal FF Play, das 4K Video, 4K 60 FPS ist auch, also super flüssig ist was anderes
wie das läuft, ja das ist jetzt ja auch lokal, also nur mal den Vergleich gemacht, also ich
brauch ungefähr 70%, also ich würd mal sagen, lokal ist ungefähr doppelt so schnell wie
im Browser, das ist rein CPU, achso, ja Moment, FF Play hat zumindest, ne ne wir sind in der
VM, das ist CPU only, also sowohl im Browser als auch in der VM ist es CPU only, wobei
ich nicht weiß, ob FF Play nicht irgendwelche OpenGL Fiveheader Sachen macht, keine Ahnung,
wie siehts mit VLC aus, wenn er das abspielt, VLC ist noch besser, VLC ist Fiveheadiger,
guck mal das braucht noch weniger, also im Browser ist schon ne ganze Ecke langsamer,
aber was erwartet man, der ganze Kram läuft, cross compile nach WebAssembly im Browser
ohne Hardware Zugriff gescheit, also ist schon, ist schon, also Performanstechnik ist wirklich
nicht schlecht, kann man nix sagen, und für normale Sachen, die man machen will reicht
es ja auch, guck mal, Video abspielen, guck mal wie schnell das das ganze rendern kann,
so wir müssen jetzt aber noch versuchen den Kram zu streamen, da bin ich echt ein bisschen
ratlos wie wir das jetzt machen, also ok, das Video abspielen funktioniert, da bin
ich schon mal froh, da haben wir wenigstens eine sinnvolle Sache heute geschafft bis jetzt,
jetzt müssen wir mal gucken wie man das mit dem, bald MemeBot mit Elektronen App Wasom
auf FFmpeg, weißt du was das bescheuerte ist, das würde sogar funktionieren, das würde
funktionieren, weißt du wo ich glaube, wo es ein bisschen Probleme haben könnte, mit
Transparenz, ne also mit Transparenz hier, da könnt ich mir vorstellen hätte die Kombi
ein bisschen Probleme, gehen würde es bestimmt mit rumprobieren, wann ist es heute spät,
22 wie immer, ok Leute habt ihr eine clevere Idee wie man das gestreamt kriegen, also
aktuell mache ich es ja so, ich uploade das Video und dann übergebe ich das Video hier,
man müsste das irgendwie gestreamt bekommen, wie bekommt man das Video gescheit gestreamt,
ich hab ne Idee, kann ich den, gestreamt, naja aktuell muss ich das Video komplett hochladen
in Browser, also quasi komplett in Browser rammen, um es dann abzuspielen und jetzt will
ich streamen, also sprich, downloaden von, nein nein nein nicht downloaden, das downloaden
ist das falsche Wort, quasi downloaden allerdings nicht in einem Rutsch, sondern immer in Häppchen
so viel wie ich brauche zum decoden, ich glaube nicht dass ich, ja FFmpeg seid ich, aber ich
habe hier keinen Zugriff auf HTTP Sachen, also müsste ich, müsste ich theoretisch ein
Download machen, ok also ich müsste irgendwo ein Download herbekommen, das kriegen wir
relativ einfach hin ein Download, hier guck mal, wobei kann ich das nicht mit Node sogar
machen, kann ich einfach sagen Node, Leute ich kopiere, ich kopiere diesen Crample einfach
rein, guck mal da, ich kopiere das Palen Video hier rein, zack, Node starten und jetzt könnte
ich es auch theoretisch schon mal downloaden, wie heißt dieser Crample, also ich mein ich
musste es in Browser machen, ist mir auch klar, aber ich will, ja ok Video Download funktioniert,
jetzt muss ich das irgendwie hier runterladen, also Fetch, Fetchen, das machen wir erstmal
im HTML, wie macht man das jetzt, also einfach Fetchen, Fetch, Fetch mit der Fetch API alleine
bringt mir ja nichts, dann lädt das ja auf einmal runter, ich muss quasi Stream, gibt
es ein Stream, Fetch Stream, Stream Response oder sowas, Using Readable Streams, Fiveheader
Kram von Mozilla wieder, Using Readable Streams, Get Reader, wat, ok das probieren wir jetzt,
was machen wir hier oben, wir machen einfach sonst nix, also, keine Ahnung, Stream Video,
ja ist egal, Fetch Video, ist eigentlich vollkommen egal wie das heißt, Async, Await, Fetch,
Async Kram, so, oh nu, was, Response Body, Get Reader, nee, war, wieso nicht den Upload
als Stream, nee ich will das gar nicht Uploaden, das soll der sich von irgendeinem Server runterziehen,
ich will doch nicht das die Leute hier irgendwie was ein Uploaden müssen, nee ich will das
komplett vom Server ziehen, den Button hier brauch ich dann gar nicht mehr, dir fehlt
ein Punkt, oh, Leute mein, mein, mein, mein, mein, mein, mein HTML Formatter ist kaputt,
ne Punkt, Village nee, auch kein Punkt, Village, das geht ja hier oft, Village ist ja der Route
ab dem Webverzeichnis, wo ich die Seite aufmache und das ist, das liegt da drin, so also was,
was muss ich jetzt mal logg und was Body, was, Get Reader, ok das habe ich noch nicht verpasst,
das hab ich noch nie verwendet. get reader. und wie rede ich da jetzt was? read. release
log. cancel closed. read. und da jetzt buffers sei es irgendwie sowas oder wie? ne wahrscheinlich
nicht oder? ne ich muss mir das beispiel angucken. ich bin da zu pepega für wie es funktioniert.
also ich will es nicht alles auf einmal downloaden. ich will eigentlich nur soweit downloaden,
dass dann, dass ich ein callback machen kann von ffmpeg und so nach dem motto jetzt wieder
irgendwie ein mb ziehen oder so. was genau bin ich sehend? was passiert hier? und was
sind? was sind? biop? streams? bring your own? bites? oder was? bring your own buffer?
oh mann also die benahmung ist ja auch immer. ach ne moment wir sind ja let. wir sind ja
massive fallferder javascript kram. warum geht mein auto format nicht mehr? mein auto
format ist kaputt. was ist denn? das? ok das heißt wenn ich jetzt await. ok let buffer
gleich await. geht das so? und was ist jetzt buffer? ein readable stream? dann value? ah
readable stream default read result. alles klar. alles klar. javascript. so value. kann
ich? gibt es nicht links oder so? links. ok. ah geh mal weg hier ohne ich muss da was
sehen. kann man die schrift hier irgendwie kleiner machen? illegal return statement.
illegal? warum? ans anzeige? der chat ist über der konsole? achja ok sekunde leute easy
ah seht ihr was wieder? so ist gut oder? der altschirm ist. readable byte stream controller
bei was denn ding? übrigens leute bevor wir das verwenden kann das safari? wurde ich
gerade gehostet oder sowas? ich glaube mein twitch spinnt gerade ein bisschen rum. ich
habe laut twitch gerade 2300 zuschauer. ich glaube das ist etwas verbackt. also dafür
ist im chat auch relativ wenig los. hallo nicht wir hatten 2300 zuschauer. aber jetzt
haben wir schon 3000 zuschauer. alles klar. das hatten wir letztens schon mal. also entweder
viewportet mich irgendein ppega oder? oder die anzeige ist falsch? keckware. twitch
gehackt ja. verwirrt mich. also mich hat keiner gehostet oder sowas. komischer komischer kram
alter. 3000 alles klar. ok wisst ihr was die sind so agil bei twitch. die sind so massive
agil. die haben continuous deployed am feiertag in produktion und haben den viewer counter
kaputt gemacht. also mit 3200 leuten in der programmier kategorie. da würde ich tatsächlich
drüber nachdenken ob ich nicht fulltime streame keckware. ich bin auf der startseite. ich
bin nicht auf der startseite. was soll ich auf der startseite machen? ok was auch immer
wir machen jetzt einfach weiter. wie soll das hier funktionieren? premium content. also
wie geht das hier weiter? oder bin ich wirklich auf der startseite? ja you like. ich weiß
gar nicht wie die startseite aussieht mittlerweile. ah booba. startseite. ja du siehst mich auf
twitch wenn du twitch startest weil. ich hab. why? wo kommen die ganzen zuschauer her?
ich würde mich jetzt ja nicht beschweren oder so. also schön dass ihr alle da seid
wer auch immer gerade da ist. ich glaube immer noch das ein anzeigefehler ist. hofft das
mal überprüfen ob das stimmt. guck mal hier mal new session. twitch.tv. ne jetzt geht
es wieder runter alles klar. ne hat sich erledigt. ich bin auch nicht auf der startseite. hat
sich erledigt. keckel. ok kurze verwirrung von twitch. es buggt. twitch buggt. wir sind
gleich wieder auf. ah jetzt. ok twitch hat es gecheckt wir sind wieder auf normalen zahlen
runter. jetzt sind wir wieder auf 260. das ist realistischer. das ist realistischer.
twitch hat in production deployed und hat es gebrickt. ok weiter im text. also chat
wie funktioniert. achso ne. unterstützt diesen krempel mozilla. äh nicht mozilla. unterstützt
denn diese stream geschichte? browser support. ähm stream. kann safari den kram? ist das?
was ist der kram? kann safari das? das ist immer die große frage. kann es safari? safari
ios. hey safari kanns. das ist ja immer so ein bisschen so ein banger moment bei web
technologien kann es safari. in der regel kannst du davon ausgehen wenn es relativ neu
ist. nein safari kann es nicht. so download. patch video. der lädt das video auf einmal
runter. was denn das? der soll das video nicht auf einmal runterladen. der soll das video
schön streamer mannen. der lädt allen ernstes. moment was ist denn das? bytes to megabytes.
äh. nein bytes. bytes. alter was warum ist das so unfähig. 2mb ach deswegen lädt er
das so schnell runter weil die datei 2mb groß ist. moment die datei ist so. wait a minute.
2mb nur? nee. ach nee moment. ich hab ja auch noch gar keine schleife oder so gemacht.
ich lade das ja nur einmalig runter. aber 2mb sind mir auch ein bisschen viel ehrlich
gesagt. ok wild true können wir jetzt eher nicht machen. äh. ok. wie bekomme ich denn
mit ob das fertig runtergeladen ist. äh. buffer? gibt es da sowas wie finish? dann.
dohne. also quasi if. dann. break. normalerweise würde ich das da oben reinschreiben mit dem
read aber ich glaube das funst nicht gescheit. ah. so. was? ist dann überhaupt keine funktion?
ach nee dann ist. äh. wo? ach condition. true. ok. ok. ok. ok. ok. ok. ok. ok. ok. ok.
ah. moment. moment. moment. das muss ich einmal hier oben machen. ah verstehe. verstehe.
reader. get reader. warum ist mein auto format im browser kaputt auf einmal. wishlist studio
code bekleggert sich heute echt nicht mit rum. ah ok. jetzt lädt er das in hapchen
runter. was hat er denn hier für hapchen? 2mb 1mb 393k? das ist ganz schön random was
der da runter lädt. nee ich mein auto format hier im wishlist studio code. weiß nicht
warum das kaputt ist. muss ich format und save anmachen nochmal? wobei ich bilde mir
eigentlich ein. das hab ich. format. guck mal mal. format. ok. hab ich format und save?
ach ich hab doch vorher meine settings gelöscht oder? save. nee auto save. nee. save. format
und save. ach jetzt funktionierts wieder. ok alles klar. die musik passt richtig gut
dazu. so also. moment. moment. das muss ich jetzt ja irgendwie blocken können. also der
soll ja nicht weiter einfach downloaden. der soll weiter downloaden wenn ich ihn anfrage
will. also so downloade ich jetzt ja wieder alles in arbeitsspeicher. so donner ich wieder
alles in arbeitsspeicher. das jetzt so donner ich die kompletten 110mb in browser arbeitsspeicher
rein. also wenn ich sie dann jetzt einlesen würde. ich. hm. wir machen jetzt mal. schau
erstmal wie ffmpeg damit klarkommt. nee wobei. genau die nächste frage ist wie krieg ich
das überhaupt in ffmpeg? wie krieg ich das überhaupt in ffmpeg? wie weit ffmpeg ist
es egal? ffmpeg schickt mir immer wenn man das mit custom input macht. ffmpeg ist kein
format. ffmpeg ist die library für das video streaming. das video selbst ist in mpeg ts.
das kann man streamen. read from standard in. nee. das wüsste ich jetzt gar nicht wie
ich das hinkriege. rüber nach c++. wie kriege ich jetzt überhaupt mal ein byte gedöns
nach c++ rüber? wie krieg ich mein byte gedöns? boah das ist ne gute frage. ich mein. ok es
gibt jetzt. also wenn ich das richtig. es gibt jetzt zwei varianten. wir könnten entweder
sowas hier machen in der richtung. hier ecstatic. ok c++. byte oder so. ah nee hc++ in byte
typ. nee. das ist uint 8. null. also wir könnten sowas hier machen. und dann noch ne
zweite funktion. und dann daraus immer lesen. aber das bringt uns ja nix. weil dann laden
wir wieder alles runter und schreiben es in raum arbeitsspeicher. das hier ist ja quasi
unser arbeitsspeicher. das funktioniert so nicht. wir müssten das pullen quasi. also
wir müssten ffmpeg sagen. so sinngemäß an der stelle. read packet. äh. ja hier so.
wenn der daten nach lädt. müsste man irgendwie ein callback machen. dann. ach du scheiße.
wie soll das funktionieren? puh. ok also wie man ffmpeg sagt das nicht aus einer datei
lesen soll. sondern dass man selbst die sachen laden kann. das weiß ich wie das funktioniert.
das hab ich schon gemacht. da kann man. dann machen wir doch das erstmal. machen wir doch
erstmal soweit das ffmpeg versucht was nachzuladen. und dann machen wir return hier und machen
nicht weiter. so. also das funktioniert nämlich folgendermaßen. ich hoffe ich krieg das aus
dem kopf noch halbwegs hin. man braucht einen avio. irgendwas kontext oder so? ne. avio.
wie hieß das? doch genau. das braucht man. äh. so das hab ich schonmal gemacht. das
weiß ich prinzipiell wie es funktioniert. so man braucht nen buffer. man braucht eine
default buffer size. man muss ihm sagen ob man schreiben möchte was wir nicht wollen.
wir wollen nur lesen. custom pointer und eine read function. rest braucht man nicht. das
hab ich schon gemacht. ich hab das allerdings in c sharp gemacht. nicht in c++. ich vermute
aber mal dass das in c++ relativ ähnlich ist. weil ffmpeg ist ja eine c library. also sprich
ähm. hier macht man es eher richtiger. also lass mal überlegen. was brauchen wir denn
jetzt? unsigned sharp buffer. ok. also ffmpeg. av. ne ach quatsch das sind c sharp so tagslool.
wir sind hier ja alles. av. ok. also speicher. wir brauchen speicher. size. auto. cackle size.
ne komm wir nennen es ordentlich. size. äh in welchen happen lesen wir immer? 4096.
auto. buffer. buffer hab ich bestimmt schon mehrfach belegt hier unten drunter. war klar
oder? war klar dass das schon belegt ist. input buffer. sowas wie ajax. ne ne ne. oder
ajax. ne ne. also ja im prinzip wir machen hier den request an den server. temp buffer
wäre auch nicht verkehrt. so size. hallo. warte. ride flag null. äh pointer brauchen
wir keine. wahrscheinlich oder? ich weiß nicht. custom pointer. warte mal wir machen
mal kurz hier ein paar einrückungen. so read packet function. äh machen wir gleich. ich
will erstmal den rest auffüllen. äh ride packet brauchen wir nicht. und eine seek function
brauchen wir auch nicht. wir können das in streamen da wird nichts gesiegt. was haben
wir hier für schmerzen? input buffer. inkompatibel. warum? ach ich muss. massive void pointer
cast. dann ist alles gut. ok jetzt brauche ich eine read function. ähm kann man hier
lambdas verwenden oder? oh da bin ich mal gespannt. mal gucken ob c plus. leute c plus
plus lambdas synthax. monkaS. äh äh so? irgendwie? und was braucht es für parameter?
void sternchen. buffer. also void. sternchen. äh oh int. 8. buffer. noch mal buffer. ich
will jetzt einfach. ne doch in der stelle passt die eigentlich. buffer. und int buff size.
weil die coolen leute kürzen hier ab. und geht das jetzt? nö. ist das die richtige
lamba synthax leute? no suitable conversion. ah moment. da muss ich irgendwas return. return
1. ah das funktioniert tatsächlich. was soll ich machen? was hat er jetzt für schmerzen?
ach moment das ist void. es muss an sein was? char muss es sein anscheinend. ah ja jetzt
funktioniert es. ok nice. das ist der horror ja? ähm also es sieht schon ein bisschen
kacke aus. das machen wir mal als eigene function oder? kann man? geht sowas? checkt
ja das. hey da checkt das. ok gut. was soll ich? bitte verwende reinterpret cast. ok.
ich verstehe nicht warum außer dass es hässlicher aussieht. reinterpret cast. ich mein warum
sollte ich es so hässlich machen wenn ich es doch einfach machen kann? also dann erklär
wer hat das geschrieben? irgendjemand der das geschrieben hat was ist daran jetzt besser?
also warum ist das jetzt geiler als das andere? der hellsniper hat es geschrieben. hellsniper
warum ist das besser? besser für die typüberprüfung vom compiler. der soll ja keine typen überprüfen.
ich mein das ist void pointer was soll der da groß überprüfen? da gibt es nix zu überprüfen.
ok wir gucken jetzt mal. versus cast versus c style. also wir lassen uns jetzt mal was
beibringen von stack overflow was der unterschied ist. c style isn't better. doch das sieht
viel besser aus. it can do many different things. also cast sollte nach möglichkeit
nicht many different things machen. was zum teufel ist das? warum ist das wieder so kompliziert?
warum ist c++ so scheiße einfach nur? gibt es da nicht eine sinnvolle erklärung zu? should
i use? ok erklär mal ordentlich. also c style cast is that they do a lot under the hood.
you should try to always use c++ cast. wisst ihr was? ich würde ja c++ casts verwenden.
aber warum alles in der welt musste man sich so eine abartige syntax davon wieder ausdenken?
ich mein ist das ein template? oder ist das ein keyword? oder was ist das? und warum ist
das ein keyword was aussieht wie ein template? die wissen selbst nicht was es ist. ne. c
plus plus hackerman zeug. bleibt jetzt c style cast. gutes. also ganz ehrlich ich finde
das nicht readable. ich finde das deutlich readable. das sieht ja auch kacke aus. so
ok jetzt war es zur eigentlichen sache. jetzt können wir ffmpeg beibringen das ffmpeg aus
einem eigenen buffer lesen kann. ich zeige euch auch das das funktioniert. btw falls
jetzt jemand sagt printf ist kein c++ style das stimmt. ich würde theoretisch sogar auch
die neue format api verwenden. aber ich kann die format api nicht verwenden weil mein wishlist
studio coder meinung ist den header gibt es nicht. hell sniper du scheinst nicht auszukehren
mit c++ vielleicht hast du eine ahnung davon warum mein wishlist studio coder meinung ist
dass es den format header nicht gibt. und ich hab meinen standard schon auf c++ 20 gestellt
teilweise sogar höher. so keck weh. beste ausgabe. so also der lädt jetzt nach sprich
wenn ich das jetzt wenn ich das jetzt kompiliere und aufrufe dann sollte der versuchen da steht
jetzt wird jetzt ah moment moment newline vergessen. ich bin ein c++ hater das stimmt
aber c++ ist ja auch kacke. so da sollte jetzt ganz auf keck w kommen klar. ne sollte nicht
ich hab das doch noch gar nicht zugewiesen. ich hab doch noch nichts zugewiesen. mpegts
ist richtig das weiß ich ja auch. so das format muss hier hin. format. und jetzt muss
ich dem noch sagen das ich glaub bp oder so ne bp was auch immer muss ich jetzt gleich
sagen so also ich mach das grad aus dem kopf das hab ich schon ne ganze weile her. also
jetzt kann man eben nämlich sagen versuche nicht selbst rauszufinden wo du die datei
her bekommst jetzt kann ich nämlich auch sagen filename ist null weil du sollst nicht aus
dem file lesen sondern mit meiner custom read function und jetzt muss man dem glaub ich
noch ein paar flex setzen ich musste dem jetzt irgendwie sagen dass das nicht boah ich weiß
es nicht ach ich ich denke immer noch ich bin in c sharp bin ich auch gar nicht ff mpeg
oder was ist denn das ff also es gibt irgendwie seek oder sowas seek seekable oder so ne black
ff black ok ich guck mal kurz was da alles so definiert ist ganz viel ganz viele flex
black bp bayer alles klar was immer die damit zu tun haben alpha auto ich muss dem irgendwie
sagen dass der nichts dass der nicht sicken kann irgendwie aber was war das jetzt noch
mal av format kontext gucken wir uns mal die ff mpeg hilfe seite ein flex av ok ok ich
hab sorry ich hab nach den falschen flex geguckt unseekable ja das das habe ich glaube ich
gesucht und jetzt muss man so machen zum ja genau das musste man sagen wenn man das stream
dass es unseekable ist doch und jetzt funktioniert jetzt sollte er versuchen zumindest diesen
ganzen graben über meine eigene read funktion zu lesen gut meine read funktion funktioniert
nicht weil die noch nichts macht hast du schon vor der rockstar programmiersprache gehört
ne es gibt so viele ppega programmiersprachen alles klar der versucht nicht zu lesen was
will er von mir
ok leute ich mach mal kurz ich mach mal kurz diese patch video geschichte weg unreachable
habe ich da irgendwas falsch gemacht ich bin mir eigentlich relativ sicher dass das so
funktioniert ok da muss ich muss ich da muss jetzt stack overflow fragen da gab es irgendeinen
ural blog einen tag der da was zugeschrieben hat stack overflow also wie machen die das
hier geil da weiß man bescheid stack overflow ja genau das will ich machen super keine antwort
der sollte oder muss ich das so machen weil er will ja eigentlich ich weiß das zu das
müsste eigentlich funktionieren ffm packdoco ist poggers ding da blickste nicht durch aber
irgendwie mal ein bescheides beispiel für hier mache ich doch open input na dami fallen
brauchen wir nicht unreachable unreachable das ist doch ein anderes problem oder ja ich
habe neu kompiliert unreachable format impact ts ja ok also bis dahin funktioniert es aber
das öffnen funktioniert nicht ja aber da sollte es zumindest einmal aufrufen um daraus
zu versuchen was zu lesen unreachable kann es sein dass er das mit dem lambda nicht checkt
hat man wollte ich jetzt einfach nur riet kann es sein dass das einfach das nicht checkt
machen also nicht wollte es sind sie nicht und machen ich würde jetzt vermuten es geht
beides weil schnicks schmeißt ein feder unreachable was will der von mir habe ich irgendwas grob
verkackt buffer size right wait a minute right flag gibt es nicht read function right function
seek function example example ja genau das will ich also aber ein ordentliches beispiel
vielleicht custom baffa sei voll ja hier ist so ein beispiel zeig mal ja also alle was das
für eine formatierung mann ok a baffa void this gibt es read function und mein dank übergibt
der null null habe ich auch read function 00 doch ok read function void int baffa baffa
sei es genau das void a baffa sei es wo ist das problem wo ist das problem jetzt warum
geht das net warum will er das net haben kann das auch direkt dahinschreiben aber was ist
das problem ich sollte mal das format weg machen dass das auto detected
unreach was will der denn von mir warum ist da irgendwas unreachable im fn war die static
unterschied macht moment null ist was anderes wie null alter z plus plus graben meine fresse
das gibt es nur in dieser sprache ich brauche mir schon lange unreach alter wo ist das problem
mann weil das wobei das mit null richtiger sein müsste weil sehr z library was was
hat er für schmerzen das geht bis zum open und da kackt er ab ok aber was anderes vorher
wir machen wir machen vorher was anderes wir lassen es mal komplett weg wir sagen jetzt
erfauen jetzt irgendwie probe probe input oder sowas ja baffa 2 meinetwegen euch doch
ich weiß woran es liegt ich weiß woran es liegt keck weight ich weiß woran es liegt
null ist ja ganz klar guck mal ob obviously leute guck mal ich hab mich drauf verlassen
dass der den speicher dafür anlegt was der ja nicht machen kann wenn ich vorher schon
was hinsetzen will das ist halt das geile an z plus plus gedürnt da kann hier so ein
kampel passieren kontext ach mann wie heißt dieser shit dafür nochmal av kontext format
das da so ok was der doktor krabu macht ich habe ich habe mich letztes zeit nicht mal
großartig was von ihm gehört das letzte mal war er bei einem deutschen auto hersteller
und hat dort high iq bvl gedürnt gemacht ah guckt mal leute ok mein browser ist jetzt
gefriest weil ich endlos schleif ab zum lesen das keine so schlaue idee gewesen aber aber
das hat habt ihr gesehen das hat funktioniert also typische typische speicher geschiss wie
es halt in cc plus plus ist was wird das eigentlich das ein video player also was kein video player
du kannst videos abspielen in formaten die der browser nicht unterstützt und jetzt sind
wir gerade dabei dass er den kram übers netzwerk zieht und nicht erst alles hochgeladen werden
muss vor allem das coole daran ist dass man es ausprobieren kann das habe ich denn erst
mal ausprobieren ja ausprobieren kannst du es auch irgendwann dass man damit eine c plus
plus library in browser bringt jonas ein auto hersteller nicht provider einem auto hersteller
ist er so also guck mal dass das hat funktioniert der liest jetzt mein zeug ein aber wir haben
das eigentliche problem das eigentliche problem noch gar nicht gelöst nämlich ach jetzt kann
ich hier bestimmt auch format hinschreiben ja guck mal mal print jetzt jetzt check nee
nee dass das wird er nicht checken also wie kriege ich und dass das wird jetzt das wird
jetzt das komplizierte ich weiß dass es links hier bei js oder irgendwie ja das habe ich
letztens gesehen das ist ziemlich feif her und es bringt halt im prinzip nichts weil
es messen langsam ist normales peißen sich auch schon langsam aber was um peißen ist
brutals langsam dafür ist in dem fall mit 10 plus plus tatsächlich besser leider ist
der c sharp web assembly support nicht sonderlich gut es gibt blazer das aber auch das einzige
was es gibt da gibt es noch uno das ist dem fehlt aber der microsoft support also und
auch die geschwindigkeit von c sharp im browser ist noch nicht sonderlich gut leider ist tatsächlich
rust und 10 plus plus go vielleicht auch ein bisschen jetzt aber tatsächlich war web assembly
ziemlich gut so also wie kriege ich leute feifei datein wie kriege ich denn jetzt also
ich habe hier meine read function guck mal hier ist meine read function wie kriege ich
diesen buffer in meine read function da braucht man jetzt richtig high iq für ich bräuchte
in javascript callback oder ich bräuchte ich bräuchte in javascript callback oder im prinzip
wartet mal sowas hier sowas hier nur umgedreht guck mal ich bräuchte ich bräuchte in javascript
callback also ich müsste jetzt quasi sagen also es gibt sie ich müsste jetzt quasi sagen
ich schreibe jetzt ich schreibe jetzt einfach mal was hin ja irgendwie patch patch data
so und und und dann müsste ich irgendwie sagen data so aber das wird ja so nicht funktionieren
so das das kann ja so nicht klappen die frage ist noch wie kriege ich das da rein jetzt
brauche ich den fall brauche ich feifei ideen vom chat also hier lese ich den hier kann ich den kram einlesen
wie kriege ich diesen krempel rüber zu c++ kann das kann das return values return return string
wenn es in string return kann dann kann das bestimmt auch ja der reader muss global sein
auf die idee bin ich auch schon gekommen ich muss nur gucken wie ich den wie bekomme ich die
daten zurück wie bekomme ich die daten raus also wie bekomme ich jetzt die die gelesenen
daten zurück vom ja vom javascript in c++ auf feifei der kram was ist das wie macht man riet ach
alter was ist das monkaS was ist das strings can be returned back to see from from from
but one needs to be careful about memory das vielleicht also ich ich guck mal nach passing
arrays between wasm and javascript da muss ich den beibringen dass dann return return
passing arrays to wasm genau
array offset man kann da pointer übergeben ernsthaft
das geht einfach so ja moment aber ich will ich kann ja ich ich brauche einen return wert
nee nee nee das hilft mir nicht ich bräuchte wie kriege ich denn jetzt mein my radar raus
also leute also das problem ist jetzt ich kann im javascript jetzt was lesen das ist ja schön
und gut ich müsste jetzt irgendeinen buffer zurück bekommen shit wie geht denn das ich
weiß ich stehe jetzt echt ein bisschen auf wie machen man das gibt es die möglichkeit dass ich
irgendeinen vector oder so da serialisieren draus ok ich muss mal kurz kommen da was da gibt es
auch emgs oder so example genau so interacting ich versuche gerade von javascript ein byte array
zu zier plus plus rüber zu bekommen allerdings web assembly nicht irgendwie war ttp emgs ok
jetzt stehe ich aber echt auf dem schlaufe kriege ich denn das kriege ich denn das rüber
ach komm mal hier ist das hier der return wert ist das hier ist das hier das was er
returned ist das hier was er returned also könnte ich quasi sowas sagen emgs und jetzt vector ok
mal gucken ob das funktioniert vector u8 t ok wie nennen wir das jetzt irgendwie keine fetsch
feckus ne irgendwie schein ok also wir müssen das klub ok jetzt jetzt jetzt fai fader time
angesagt messer fai fader time point da bringt man ich brauche ich brauche die länge ich brauche
den pointer und die länge also im vector vielleicht realisiert er das ja für mich irgendwie schon so
kein load more so ist schon ok so so heißt es jetzt so kann ich das kann ich jetzt aufrufen
einfach so laut data ok das würde funken in die backslash n dollar die und jetzt gucken wir mal
data length die size ist es glaube ich beim buffer warum weil die sich da nicht entscheiden können
so jetzt ist noch die frage wie kriege ich das hin laut data muss ich ja auch mehrfach auf ich
könnte auch iterator irgendwie aber ich glaube das ist keine so gute idee das heißt geht doch
nicht warum was hat er für schmerzen was was stört ihn jetzt bitte schön da dran ach ist das
so also ok da mal das was bei streit gesagt hat das eine gute idee der reader muss public sein
machen wir das weg der reader muss public sein also da a weight is only valid in async functions
javascript nervlich alda ok der reader ok da war es anders let reader function set up muss
jetzt mal kurz reichen async patch reader reader so wunderbar perfekt beste set up so jetzt ist ok
jetzt haben wir reader können wir auf reader jetzt hier zugreifen warum du erwähnt ist nein ich
erwähnte um den reader zu getten um das response objekt zu haben das den reader getten kann an der
stelle lädt er noch nicht runter anscheinend fragt mir nicht macht er nicht macht er nicht
der lebt nacheinander runter so ok reader also kann ich jetzt sagen in load data könnte ich
jetzt sagen das probieren wir jetzt erstmal aus ob das prinzipiell hier funktioniert console log
reader wir geben einfach die reader aus mal gucken ob das funktioniert wobei das wird
wahrscheinlich kompilieren weil ich hier kein array zurückgebe der lädt wahrscheinlich ab
sofort korrekt ja gehe ich auch von aus der lädt ab sofort und dann alles klar ok es wird jetzt
crashen aber wir sollten zumindest den reader hier drin sehen ob das funktioniert hey es
funktioniert leute default reader ok ich habe meinen browser wieder gekillt weil endlos schleife
vielleicht sollte ich da vielleicht soll ich da aus prinzip noch mal ein kleines ein kleines
sleep rein machen wobei ich brauche kein sleep ich brauche kein sleep der leht ja im ende doch
doch doch doch zum zum testen zum testen mache ich da ein kleines kleines lieb rein eine sekunde
reicht da schon moin chain law ich habe dich letztens in einem stream rumspermen sehen ich
weiß nicht mehr wo das war du hast aber teilweise genauso random sachen gespammt wie hier ich habe
mich aber nicht zu erkennen gegeben dass ich dich beobachtet habe ok also reader wie war
das jetzt nochmal reader read reader read a weight a weight reader reads und dann value value ok
also das müssen wir jetzt hier machen let buffer wie viel buffer sich hier schon habe so return
buffer value pack alle aber wenn das jetzt funktioniert dann dann muss ich aber mal
kacken da muss ich hardcore kacken wenn das funktioniert auf warnings warnings generated
lu ok warum auch immer ja glaube ich auch chain war so auf fack was jetzt so a weight reader an
expected tauchen warum heute warum ist das unexpected das doch richtig
using 64 bit arguments in ist not war so ein big end wo benutze ich denn 64 bit argumenten
wo wo sind da 64 bit argumenten ich sehe nix ach so dass es kein async ist ja das kann sein
load data
64 bit argumenten wo ist da wo sich der 64 bit argument ich sehe hier keins ich lasse
jetzt einfach ich sehe da ich sehe da wirklich kein ok wir müssen das wir müssen das async
machen async asyncify jawoll gibt es das vielleicht mit mit ach guck mal async poggers muss ich das
jetzt hier auch awaiten wenn man das liebt davor weil ansonsten weiß ich nicht ob es
umbackt was will er also ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung was das mir damit sagen möchte
hier load data has see linkage best specified but returns ein schimmer was sagt was sei kämpel wieder von mir will ok
aborted ok das funktioniert so schon mal nicht warum warum abort aborted an court
assertion fehlt ja ok welche was genau soll ich das ich lasse sleep mal weg vielleicht macht das
lieb kaputt das muss man doch anderweitig nach java script bekommen als mit so eine müll oder
das kann doch nicht sein was was fehlt also der macht doch nicht man der macht noch nicht mal
den read hier der macht noch nicht mal den read return buffer value also die fehlermeldung ist
auch wieder äußerst nicht sagen chat ich habe keine ahnung was er was er mir was er mir sagen
möchte runtime assertion fehlt kann ich kann ich vielleicht nicht den buffer return an der stelle
ich habe da ich habe eine andere idee guck mal wir machen wir machen wir machen so eine global function
function load data so und der macht im prinzip genau das gleiche dann muss ich da brauche ich
nicht da brauche ich nicht c++ in java script und so in so einem müll wobei ich jetzt natürlich
nicht weiß was das return fack der fehler ist im java script wahrscheinlich aber ich weiß nicht
warum load data gucken wir mal was hier passiert jetzt cannot read property of undefined reading
reads super super fehlermeldung reader ist wo sich den wahr machen kann das sein dass sonst
nicht geht wenn er nicht war es ane moment moment ne fack alle ich bin verwirrt ich bin ich bin ich
bin ich bin verwirrt der wartet mal ich kann das nicht erwarten weil das top level ist so
die buffer read geht das so geht das funktioniert alles klar log ok dass das funktioniert ja es muss
ein sing weil sonst kann ich nicht reden
ah du hast recht ja das wird tatsächlich funktionieren in dem fall ich glaube das
lag schon daran dass ich das nicht nicht war stimmt in dem fall könnten das tatsächlich
so machen zum ausprobieren wenn einfach nur wissen ob prinzipiell das funktioniert weil
ich da getrieben habe nee was so hat javascript sonntags alter so
sollte er nicht jetzt was ausführen hat er führt auch was aus der lockt aber den buffern ich
ok nice nice also da da da kommt was raus ok not value ok gut da war das weg
exakt so kommt der krempel jetzt rüber nach z plus plus make vielleicht kann
er auch den vector nicht sie realisieren schauen wir mal also so das sieht auch schon mal gut
aus der download den shit immerhin der download den shit und dann kack da beim return ab ok
vector returnen ist wohl nicht schauen wir mal ob ins returnen denn geht
da sollte jetzt einfach rauskommen sleep ich ich lasse das ding ich lasse ich lasse
ich lasse den echt mal ein sleepen weil ansonsten kackt mir der browser immer ab
ok also vector return geht an der stelle schon mal nett wo wir das problem wie
kriege ich den kram von javascript zu z plus plus die mal immer anschmeißen
weil wenn wir das haben ist das mit dem stream gar nicht mal so gar nicht so schwierig ok ins
ins returnen funktioniert vector returnen kann man ok m scripten return vector
im binden naja goanna standard standard vector besser also was was kann er dann
bild in type konvers konversions bool sein char kann er point das standards
leute ich könnte einfach ein standard string als buffer missbrauchen was was haltet ihr von
der idee ich ich ich returne einfach in standard string von meinem und tut dann halt so als wäre
es kein string das müsste doch funktionieren zumal der standard string interessiert sie
eh nicht für otf 8 oder sonst was das sind ja eigentlich noch bei ach guck mal hier for
convenience m bind provides factory functions to register standard vector das ist doch gut
machen wir register vector infektor int was das so heißen
struts warum heißt das struts modul heißt struts und so und jetzt schauen wir ob das
funktioniert das wäre extrem feif wenn das jetzt funktioniert u int acht post
schimpf habe ich das richtig gemacht miss was jetzt errohr load data achso ich hab ne print
ja dass ich noch eins achso nicht ja beides ich returne noch eins und das hier muss was
sein ld oder sowas und dann data size und hier return ja return also hier oben buffer
buffer value was eigentlich was ein rum geht ok das muss das muss noch schöner gemacht
werden das ist doch nicht aber wenn es funktioniert wäre mir ja schon mal ganz recht warum kompiliert
das eigentlich drei stunden ok post schimpf leute post schimpf was ist das warum geht
das net vor allem die meldung ist richtig pepega also das liegt auf jeden fall das
liegt auf jeden fall an an diesem return type der rum backt ok wir probieren mal an standard
ring geht das jetzt kann das auch sei soll ich das soll ich das einfach mal rein machen
was im beginnt leute wie mache ich denn wie mache ich denn was kann ich irgendwie dieses
load data synchron machen sodass ich es nicht erwarten muss dass das hier funktioniert
ohne dass ich es erwarten muss weil dann könnte ich das hier direkt drin verwenden ja ich glaube
auch dass niemand sowas vorgesehen hat was was was hat er sein problem mit using 64 bit
arguments async load data type i warum ist das immer blöde frau warum ist das denn
soll ich das ich übergibt es jetzt einfach warum ist das hier load data ok ich meine
vielleicht hat es andere probleme aber aber was was will es denn von mir überhaupt kann
ich nicht ok kann ich nicht einfach was anderes blödes kann ich sowas return
dürfte doch im leben nicht funktionen das müsste das gibt ja memory leaks ohne ende
dann shit also was was will was will er mir mit teilen big end ist not supported ja gut
komm wenn big end not supported ist dann supporten wir jetzt einfach big end das ist schon ist
big end supported ich habe zwar immer noch keine ahnung wo hier irgendwas ach ist das
vielleicht weil das ein pointer ist wo er sagt 64 64 bit ist das weil es ein 64 bit
pointer ist ich war mal was anderes wie kann man denn ein new in things array anlegen wir
lassen das mit dem fetsch einfach mal weg also in things kann man das irgendwie initialisieren
dass man sagt irgendwie 1 2 3 so also wie wir retörnen wir machen einfach mal sink so
return das und ansonsten gar nichts einfach diesen ganzen mist wieder weg ich probiere
das noch mal mit dem vector weil die haben jetzt registrat und acht mal gucken ob es
jetzt nicht abkackt weil da kann jetzt nicht da kann jetzt nicht wirklich was falsch gehen
was was schief gehen an der javascript seite an dieser stelle hat er vielleicht mit load
data das problem weil ich doppelt benannt habe das könnte sein guck mal die funktion
gibt es mehrfach nicht dass der nicht dass er deswegen rumspackt hey das funktioniert
ok ich bin jetzt trotzdem mal ich mache hier die load data einfach wieder weg auch mal
probieren das das funktioniert leute das das das scheint das scheint zu funktionen wir
gucken jetzt erstmal ob das funktioniert wir gucken jetzt erstmal ob das funktioniert
was muss ich machen llu data size da sollte jetzt ja drei rauskommen
also null sollte da nicht rauskommen
ok was will der mir hiermit sagen was was was will der
es ist wahrscheinlich nicht schlimm oder weil es ja durch den c++ compiler ja null man ok
wir müssen uns noch mal noch mal das ganze objekt habe ich doch hier schon total aufgemacht
das hat funktioniert oder meins hier
ich weiß gar nicht wie kann man die adresse von dem ding loggen funktioniert das wenigstens
sie wobei ich könnte ich könnte irgendwie suchen da jetzt auf ok sehr schön
vodka was
Was?
If Def C++?
Was will er von mir?
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was der mir damit sagen will, Alter.
Moment, ich hab doch damit nur...
Jetzt, jetzt merke ich einfach wieder von, von 64 Spit.
Jetzt merke ich einfach wieder mit 64 Spit rum, Alter.
Wasen beginnt, Minus S, Wasen beginnt, alles klar, mach ich jetzt.
Ich habe hier nur die Warnings ausgeschaltet hier gerade.
Keine Ahnung, wie ich da irgendwas rüber gepiped kriege.
Moment, das kann doch sogar stimmen, Leute, das kann doch sogar stimmen, das kann sogar
stimmen.
Okay, kann mir jetzt irgendjemand noch erklären, was das mit, was das mit Big-In-Support zu
tun hat?
Weil das checke ich nicht, ach, das ist nur die Adresse, ich kack noob, Alter, das ist
nur die Adresse, die ich logge, das ist komplett falsch, was ich mache, Alter, das ist nur
die Adresse, das funktioniert überhaupt nicht, eh, funktioniert immer noch nicht.
Nochmal, was ein Try and Error, eh, Null, okay, wie, ich bin jetzt echt, keine Ahnung,
wie ich den Krempel zurückkriege, EMGS, da muss es doch, da muss er mal gescheite Examples
für geben, Alter, String, die Size-Funktion, die gibt's.
Auto-Convert, nicht void, was, return mal Byte-Offset vom Uint-Array als Charpoint,
als Charpointer, log das erste Element, also du meinst, du meinst, ich soll sowas hier
returnen, oder wie, und dann, und dann quasi so, so was da, oder wie, da sollte jetzt eins
rauskommen, was, Byte, Byte-Offset, Moment, was, hat das, hat das was, was Byte-Offset
heißt das, ach so, was macht das, the Offset in Bytes, wie, was für ein Offset, Offset
von was, ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was, was das machen soll, Offset, Offset von was,
ja, aber von was, von, oh guck mal da, 101 kommt da raus, 101 ergibt wenig Sinn, oder,
da kommt aber reproduzierbar 101 raus, Leute, da kommt immer 101 raus, warum kommt da 101
raus, ich, ich hab wirklich keine Ahnung, Byte-Offset, Uint, ach, was, was ist der Byte-Offset,
das ist manjaro, E3wm, Leute, ihr müsst ja das schon so schreiben, dass ich das verstehe,
was soll denn ein Byte-Offset überhaupt machen, das ließ nichts aus dem Buffer, doch, das
doch da das gibt das ding hier zurück als was auch immer character array hier
auch immer und da liest was raus
was sind das dahinten überhaupt was sind das parameter
ane das ist parameter für für hier moment moment moment moment kann ich ane das sind
parameter die stamm ist das jetzt ich mache gar nichts ich tippe nichts warum ist es jetzt auf
einmal das 1 2 3 er ist nicht sinnvoller klar ist es sinnvoll um zu sehen ob es funktioniert
bei offset call function bei offset array length ja ich muss zwei sachen übergeben die länge
und was was genau macht array offset ich habe das immer noch nicht verstanden
from the start was was was macht das ding wird drei drei das ist doch null also das
müsste doch am anfang sein ok ich habe keine ahnung ich mache das jetzt einfach ich weiß
nicht was ist was es machen macht aber weit offset alles klar weit offset da ist ein
kommer nach der klammer ja das absicht das absicht das ist ein makro was daraus dann
eine funktion macht frag mich nicht weil c++ shit 101 das interessiert ihn mal so gar nicht
wie kriege ich daten daraus man das kann er nicht so schwer sein also ins kann ich übergeben
ins ins kann ich übergeben also kann ich ein int zurückgeben dass ich dann zu einem pointer
um den sie die sache ist bloß die wartet mal hier gibt es ein beispiel zeig mal her
das geht ja nicht dass er der return wert was du loggst array index null in zahler 41 ja
ja warum habe ich das gemacht weil der chat geschrieben hat ich soll das machen
den sinn davon verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt anett aber das steht in der steht in dem
beispiel er hier so drinnen so in das irgendwie in der richtung wenn er wenn er das checkt
mit dem ich hätte eigentlich erwartet dass es so funktionieren muss rufen wir aus dem
richtigen buffer daten ab das ist doch ein richtiger buffer das ist ein richtiger buffer
mit 123 drinnen das muss doch das muss doch so funktionieren wie ist er nicht natürlich
das ist das gleiche was ich aus dem buffer raus kriege guck da muss hier buffer machen
wait a minute was ist das jetzt schon wieder für ein shit
was ist denn das array buffer alter java script das muss doch mal irgendjemand verstehen
ja u int 8 array also das ja hast du buffer was returns array buffer reference warum sollte
ich das machen raw bainer bainer wie buffer ok bei der dann ok alles klar meine güte waffer
so wer denkt sich also ich mein ganz ehrlich ja was gibt und c++ in kombination also ich
mein warum setzt sich sowas durch null null ist auch nicht gut es sollte eins sein
ich verstehe auch nicht habe keine ahnung man das ich mein das kann doch nicht so nicht
so schwierig sein da was da da rauszukriegen 101 was will damit sein verkackte 101 ok was
was lu hundert eins was ist mit 101 ich mache den cast falsch wahrscheinlich ich habe keine
ahnung ist das überhaupt das richtige printf statement 0 das ergibt keinen sinn doch ergibt
sind also lu muss ich machen sagte lu ok also ich habe ich habe legit keine ahnung wie ich
hiervon was rüber bekomme wirklich ich keine ahnung wie war das andere s sing kompiliert
das jetzt überhaupt noch wenn ich es machen 101 ist wenn ich das erste element lese das
erste element ist ja noch nicht mal initialisiert in dem fall es zeigt irgendwo random hin
weil weil der vector angeblich null ist guck doch mal wie man ordentlich vector return
ja wenn du ein beispiel dafür findest ich finde da keins für sobald man das erst macht
ist es ist es assertion fehlt data ist standard vector also wie das was hier zurückkommt
mensch da muss es doch ein beispiel für geben man da muss es doch ein beispiel für
geben ich mein was macht der dude hier ja das gibt er als parameter das bringt mir nichts
ich brauchen return und return value ich brauche ich brauche return value da ja das ist wirklich
painsthemp alter painsthemp passing out arrays
arrays to vasem ops meine klima lag hat sich einfach resettet gerade von ks warum macht
die denn sowas gesetzt okay ich check ich check passing arrays muss es doch ein ordentliches
beispiel geben für da habe ich jetzt backseat kein problem weil ich checks gar nicht da
muss es doch ok google vector to c++ nicht zu javascript uint 8 array to get c++ uint
array to js auch ok ja was ne das was anderes ich will es umgedreht ich will es umgehen
genau das will ich machen das no way along was ja das ist mir klar dass ich nicht direkt
auf javascript memory buffers zugreifen kann aber ich kann auf ich kann ja drauf zugreifen
auf die daten die muss man irgendwie serialisieren ist das pfeiffert das threadformer info news
group sind wir jetzt schon in irgendwelche google news dingern angelangt hier ok hier
das hat man aber das ich gerade schon m script wall class m script wall class ist provided
bei m bind return moment ich kann in ich kann in jason ob ich kann ein komplettes javascript
objekt zurück nach c++ geben das ist bestimmt nicht so gedacht aber also wenn das gehen
es geht keine waffe ja länge ist jetzt erstmal egal das gibt jetzt wobei keine ahnung ob
ich das brauche mal überlegen gleich ne das brauche ich nicht das kann ich ja da auslesen
drauf und jetzt was wahl moment die haben eine eigene variablen typ der wahl heißt
das ist echt nicht wahl was geht nicht achso conversation was was bin ich was bin ich exakt
hier sehend gerade was was was ist das ist das ist es t++ oder ist es javascript was
sehe ich hier
moment das ist gerapptes das ist gerapptes javascript c++ ok was muss ich return wahl
ok das sieht gut aus ist ein schaffler sind sich uneinig na gut jetzt habe ich den krempel
hier in jetzt habe ich ein objekt hier drüben aber wie kriege ich den buffer denn da raus
gibt es irgendwas array 2 ne wäre auch zu schön vector was random shit alter
converting each element ok moment was wahl
wahl hat einfach schon mal kein auto ah moment das muss ich inkluden das muss ich inkluden
das habe ich echt gemacht ich hege auch kroll ich hege richtig kroll wahl
muss ich ja m scripten wahl schreiben ok jetzt ist einfach jetzt ist einfach komplett
leute jetzt jetzt ist komplett denied autocomplete jetzt ist jetzt ist vorbei jetzt ist autocomplete
abgekackt jetzt geht gar nichts mehr jetzt jetzt wills nicht mehr jetzt ist komplett
brischel studio code verreckt kacktul alter
ach nee ich hätte vorher auch schon wahl machen können ach so ich habe falsche koll
ich habe keine ahnung was hier was ich hier sehe es kann ich jetzt einfach sagen es vector
aber das ist also wenn das funktioniert kann das nicht die schöne die schöne art sein
das zu machen auto kackel was ok das kompil was jetzt immer noch der
gleiche mal präge also ganz im ernst dass das man auch mal daten von javascript zurück
nach z++ bringen muss hätte auch einer dran denken können so was achso ja ok ist gut nochmal
meine güte was ein was ein kram das ist das ist wirklich fünf kopf extrem 6 6 herrer
was ich will es anklicken
cannot use deleted wahlhändel ist da was deleted
warum ist da was deleted was klar da guck return
benutzt new und einen wahl pointer was warum soll ich new verwenden das javascript objekt
was ich zurückgebe oder wie jetzt ich meine ich kann mir das mit der länge ja eigentlich
sparen oder data es oder oder soll ich mal das andere verwenden hier was haben wir hier
convert js array to vector data was jetzt das problem
ich habe auch keine ahnung ich weiß ich weiß nicht was ich hier mache
welcher der blog post ich einen letzten 22 und 50 blog post offen
was ist denn jetzt deleted
oje ich hab keinen life mehr heute ok weil es emjs makro hier int
uns charstern was welche ausgeburt der hölle ist das hier
das liest er etwa den kommentar aus was so ja aber woher weiß er denn jetzt wie wie
lang das array überhaupt achso ja gut das ist ein charter da ist ein null terminator
hinten dran em fall moment moment was ist das hier aha aha aha was ist hier muss man
das so return aus irgendwelchen gründen ist das ist das nicht erlaubt in properly terminator
makro vielleicht vielleicht darf ich das nicht in line schreiben sondern muss irgendwie
keine anklage sein let pack w gleich so was ne auto scheiß drauf data ok jetzt weiß
er nicht was es ist der weiß nicht was data ist muss ich das jetzt weil weil und wie liest
er das dann später aus was und wo macht jetzt feind mein input
er hat sich hier auch verschrieben was take ownership 5 hat ein mann das ist ja das ist
ja absolut advances advances der 6 hat aller zeiten hier ok das frister ich hab keine
ahnung was ist erstmal ich habe keine ahnung ok um sekunde ok ich probiere jetzt einfach
ob das ob das funktioniert
sonst mache ich das wie das da drüben steht
wo ist die musik wo läuft die musik überhaupt habe ich das jetzt schon kompiliert
all take ownership load data wtf
das funktioniert ich hab keine ahnung was ich da gerade überhaupt gemacht habe alter
was zum was ist das überhaupt was ich da sehe ok jetzt mit echten dann also erstmal
gucken ob das er so gachi bass noch funktioniert
was auf das kack jetzt ab mit warum warum binden die das nicht für mich im hintergrund
um mit dass es dass ich das direkt return was weil was ist das hierfür für und vor
allem warum ich will ja kein javascript objekt returnen ich will einfach nur das funktioniert
ok funst ok also jetzt sagen wir ok bar erst mal weg waffel read du du du du du du du du
du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du wir
sind vier stunden fast schon an diesem dreck dran alle ok wir haben uns auch viel schon
über C++ aufgekriegt. So, jetzt genießt ihr aus dem echten Buffer. Moment, irgendwas
habe ich falsch gemacht. Await, Reader? Warte mal, das ist JavaScript. Cannot convert und
define. Reader? Da ist er doch, der Reader. Ach, Value! Glaube ich.
Nee, nee, ich glaube, das ist falsch. Exzellent, das funktioniert, Leute! Und jetzt ist halt
alles runtergeladen. Es funktioniert, er downloadet. Es funktioniert. Aber mal ganz im Ernst, das
kann es doch jetzt nicht sein hier, oder? Aber das kann es doch jetzt nicht, das ist
doch abartig. Warum kann ich jetzt nicht einfach den, direkt den Kram, ich will mich jetzt
mal nicht beschweren. Okay, also, Take Ownership. Keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht. So, okay, das
ist... Size ist okay, Size können wir da drin stehen lassen, in Ordnung. Wo kann man
sich nicht beschweren? Warum macht man überhaupt C++ WebAssembly? Ach, du meinst hier, dass
er so schnell lebt. Naja, weil man eine Library verwenden will, die besonders gut mit C++
funktioniert und man den Kram irgendwie im Browser laufen lassen will. Freiwillig bestimmt,
naja, gut, freiwillig. Freiwillig ist es alles, aber freiwillige Technologie-Auswahl in dem
Fall ist es nicht. So, also, wir haben jetzt, okay, okay. Moment, Leute, wie kriegen wir
jetzt die Länge hier raus? Das hier ist doch jetzt ein Vektor, ne? Ach, Moment, ich muss
das ja noch in diesen Buffer hier reinschreiben, dass das funktioniert. Also, vor? Oh ne, Leute,
oh Gott, fuck, guck mal, wenn der Buffer hier jetzt länger ist als mein Input-Buffer, was
mache ich dann? Okay, wisst ihr was? Mir ist es egal. Static, das ist eh Single-Threaded,
ne? Globale Variable am Start. Kegwe, da ist das Ding. So. So, GlobalChamp. GlobalChamp.
So, perfekt. Der GlobalChamp. Schauen wir mal, ob das funktioniert. Der GlobalChamp,
der denkt übrigens immer noch, ist undefined, aber was auch immer. Wie heißt nochmal das
Media-Sender, das Streaming-Team, den du auf dem TV hättest? Also, Kodi und, also, ich
verwende ein Shield-TV mit Kodi drauf. So, das siehst du hier. Also, das rein, das Wohnzimmer-Setup
kannst du dir, aber das hat mit VU Plus nix zu tun. Also, rein die, rein die Hardware und
das Media-Sender kannst du dir in dem Video angucken. Also, so ist Kodi und Media-Sender
und das ist das Shield-TV hier unten. Das ist der Android-TV-Box. Kannst dir die explizit
Android-TV-Box nennen. So, und auf der VU Plus-Seite habe ich TV Headend. Dafür brauchst
du allerdings OpenART-TV anstatt von VU Plus. Was mir persönlich auch deutlich lieber ist,
weil VU Plus hat zwar theoretisch so ein paar proprietäre Tuner-Geschichten, aber TV Headend
kann schnell genug umschalten, zumal mit 8 Tunern hat man da eh kein Problem. Aber dafür
ist VU Plus hoffnungslos veraltet, was die Lidlungs-Seite angeht, aber komplett. Da
ist OpenART-TV deutlich besser. Nochmal kurz checken, ob das funktioniert. Der GlobalChamp.
Ich meine, wir lesen nur aus einem Thread. Da kann ja nix passieren. Kappa. Nee, aber
da kann da theoretisch wirklich nix passieren. Wir haben sogar mal einen Stream gemacht, da
kann man sich TV Headend selbst kompilieren führen. Ja, sonst. Irgendwann sollte er aber
abkacken, weil er am Ende ist. Ja, gut, hier kackt er ab, weil er am Ende ist. Alles klar.
Vielleicht kriegen wir das jetzt noch gebacken. Vielleicht kriegen wir das jetzt. Ich muss
gleich schon was essen, Leute. Ich hab nix, 2-3 Minuten mehr gefuttert. Vielleicht gucken
wir nachher noch ein paar Videos zur Bedgetime und ich futter dann hier was. Also, der GlobalChamp.
Okay, jetzt wird's eklig, Leute. Jetzt wird's richtig eklig. Ich hab aber keine Ahnung,
wie ich das anders als mit einer globalen Variable machen soll. Also, ich muss jetzt
gucken, also wir machen ne Schleife. Wir machen ne Schleife. Buffer-Size. Das gibt auf jeden
Fall Probleme, das wird so nicht funktionieren. Buffer gleich GlobalChamp E. So. Okay, jetzt
geht's los. Ähm. So, das funktioniert nicht, weil es kann jetzt sein, dass dort mehr drinne
ist oder weniger drinne ist. Gibt es so was wie math.min? Wie hieß denn das min? Was?
Leute. C++. Was ist das? Oh Gott, meine Güte, Mann. Warum ist das so beschissen benannt,
das in dieser Kacksprache? So. Nee. Hä? Wait a minute. Was? Cons.tpa. Ich will einfach
wissen, was das kleinere ist davon. Es ist standard min. Aber wie soll man bei dieser
Hilfe denn darauf kommen, dass man hier Zahlen reinstecken kann? Alter. Oh Mann. Diese Sprache,
ey. So. Auto-Size. So, und jetzt gucken wir mal. Was ist größer? Der GlobalChamp-Size
oder Buff-Size. Und nur so lang lassen wir die Schleife laufen. Ich müsste jetzt. Okay,
und jetzt müsste auch geht das überhaupt? Kann man aus dem Buffer kann man da wieder
was löschen? Remove oder so? Erase? Kann man am Anfang des Buffers, des Vektors? Delete
Front? Geht das? Nee, ich will nicht alles löschen. Ich will bloß ein paar Sachen
vorne löschen. Erase. Erase. Okay. Das ist zwar nicht sonderlich effizient. Ich will
es nicht auf Null setzen. Ich will es nicht auf Null setzen. Ich will Erase. Ich weiß
überhaupt nicht, ob das stimmt, was ich hier zusammenfabriziere. Ich will die Anzahl der
eingelesenen Sachen löschen. So. Und wenn und nur wenn GlobalChamp-Size gleich gleich
Null ist, laden wir nach. Wir haben einen Command, ich weiß nicht, ob das für heute
angepasst ist. Also was für was ich gemacht habe ist, ich habe einen Videoplayer gebaut
mit FFmpeg, was komplett im Browser läuft. C++ zu WebAssembly und er kann auch Sachen
abspielen von Codex, der der Browser nicht unterstützt. Und jetzt, oh fuck, Alter. Und
jetzt versuche, was hat er denn für Schmerzen? Und jetzt versuche ich grad. Warum? Muss man
da irgendwas einbinden für? Include Algorithms. Ach du Gott. Wer diesen Kram organisiert,
okay, das mag er trotzdem nicht. Also diese Sprache macht mich echt fertig. Was soll
ich da casten? Warum? Hä, warum soll ich was? Der findet Standardmin nicht. Da bringt
mir doch nichts dazu, zu casten. Eine Type-Message? Was? So, ich hab die Auswahl, Size-T und Buff-Size.
Ah, das kann er nicht, intern oder was? Was ist denn da von größer? Size-T wahrscheinlich,
oder? Äh, muss ich das auch wieder casten? Ja, das kann er nicht, intern oder was? Was
ist das? Wer denkt sich diese Scheiß-Standard-Library aus, Alter? Meine Güte, Mann. Was machen
die denn den ganzen Tag da, auf ihren Sitzungen? Ich mein, es wäre ja zu logisch, dass man
sagt, erase einfach mal die ersten 20 Elemente und steck dann da ne Zahl rein. Nee, das geht
natürlich nicht. Und jetzt, wie erase ich da was? Vectorbeginn plus 5! Ernsthaft! Vectorbeginn
plus 5! Alter, was ist das für ein Bullshit? Sekunde, ich muss kurz muten. Mein Herz hat
alles kaputt gegangen. So, okay. Geht wieder. Das ist doch nicht euer Ernst! Ich mein, wirklich,
was? Was brauchst du für ein Gehirn, um dir sowas auszudenken? Das ist komplett ab, wenn
du da mehr als drei Zeilen drin machen musst. Was? Warum? Ich mein, was muss dich reiten,
sowas da einzubauen? Das hat doch legit keinen Sinn. Und wenn? Und wenn? Okay, ich lass mir
das gefallen, wenn man sagt, okay, ich hab nen Iterator, der geht bei 5 los und ich will
von da 5. Okay, aber warum macht man dann keinen Overload rein, der ne stinknormale
Zahl akzeptiert? Das löscht jetzt aber nur Global Champ Size. Das löscht die ersten
Dinger. Das ist okay. Das müsste doch eigentlich Sinn ergeben, was ich hier gebaut hab. Keine
Ahnung, das ist abartig, das ist C++, aber ich weiß grad wirklich nicht anders, wie
ich. Äh, das ist auf jeden Fall nicht richtig. Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht richtig.
Moment, der löscht nur ein Element? Wie? Der löscht nur ein Element. Achso! Ernsthaft,
wirklich! Alter, du musst doch selig fertig sein, dass du sowas entwirfst, oder? Du musst
doch, du musst doch irgendwie, mir fällt gar nichts ein, was du da für Vorerkrankungen
brauchst, dass du dir sowas ausdenkst als Library. Was? Guckt euch mal an, wie beschissen
so ein hässlicher Kram, Alter. Ey, das sieht ganz gut aus. Äh, der fängt ja von, ach
ne! Ah ne ne, das ergibt Sinn. Das ergibt Sinn, was da passiert. Leute, ich glaube,
dass das prinzipiell funktioniert. Wobei der nicht so weit einlesen sollte. Und so viel
kann der eigentlich auch nicht einlesen, weil, okay, ich hab irgendeinen Logikfehler, Leute.
Ich hab da gar nicht irgendeinen Logikfehler drin, weil das, das ist mir ein bisschen zu
viel, was der einliest. Ich hab aber grad absolut keine Ahnung mehr, wo der Fehler ist. Moment,
ich returne immer nur eins, ja, kein Wunder, das kann ja nicht funktionieren. Äh, ich
muss returnen, size. Aber trotzdem, der hätte schon längst abkacken müssen vorher. Der
hätte vorher schon längst abkacken müssen, weil er nicht mal weiter lesen kann. Load
data müsste er schon längst am Ende sein zum Lesen. Okay, ich muss mal kurz, ich brauch
mal kurz ne kleine Debug-Ausgabe. Äh, reload, keine Ahnung, wie ich es nennen soll. So,
diesen size Scramble mach ich mal weg. Ich will einfach sehen, ob der sich neue Sachen
abruft, ab und zu mal. Wobei, ich kann das ruhig drinnen lassen, ist in Ordnung. Aber
das hier ist ja nur wirklich, ich mein, okay, man könnte irgendeine Q nehmen oder so anstatt
im Vektor, lass ich mir alles gefallen, aber das ist ja nur wirklich. Ähm, ja, das ist
gut, das funktioniert. Leute, er erkennt, dass es MPEG-TS ist. Ah ne, das hat er noch
von hier. Okay, Moment, dass es MPEG-TS ist, also, okay, ähm, Format, wir wollen, wir
wollen nicht das, Moment, das wollen wir nicht, wir wollen, wollen wir das so machen? Ähm,
wir wollen, äh, Probe, Probe, Buffer, äh, okay, es gibt Probe-Buffer und Probe-Buffer
2, das ist auch schon mal ganz tolle Benamungskunst. Also, Buffer 2, Returns, Score, ne, ich will
einfach nur wissen, was, Probe-Buffer, ähm, so, was brauche ich jetzt noch? AV-Format?
Ey, was, was, alter, was will der da von mir haben, was für ein Pointer? Hallo, Autocomplete,
Visual Studio, please, zeig mir an, was der haben will. Jetzt wird er kaputt. Alter, wir
haben ja heute nur die Profitools am Start hier. Ach, wahrscheinlich, weil ich da oben drüber
was hingeschrieben habe. AV-Input-Format, AV-Input-Format, okay, Format, das ist bestimmt
oben schon belegt, hatte ich das nicht oben schon mal belegt? Ne, war ich nicht. Ah, da
unten, ne, das, das, das ergibt ja so keinen Sinn. Format, gleich, gleich null, das ist
ein, das ist ein Format, Pointer, so, ähm, Probe, Format, da muss ich jetzt Adresse auf
einen Pointer übergeben, weil Pointer, Pointer, url, gibt's nicht, äh, kann man da null sagen
wahrscheinlich, null, Lock, null, ähm, Offset, äh, was für ein Offset, null, Max-Probe-Size,
null, ich hoffe, ich hoffe, dass das Default ist, möb, danke für den Sub, so, und jetzt,
äh, sollte das eigentlich weiterhin funktionieren, er sollte die ersten, bla, bla, bla, wie viel
auch immer, Bites einlesen und mir sagen, dass es MPEG-TS ist, das ist, es funktioniert,
es ist MPEG-TS, das heißt, er hat jetzt die ersten, er hat jetzt die ersten paar Bites
eingelesen und hat in den Buffer geguckt und dann festgestellt, ah, das muss MPEG-TS sein,
ist schon mal gut, und danach konnte er auch den Kontext öffnen, alles klar, jetzt mach
ich das Return raus und es funktioniert einfach, ah, ne, es ist, bricht ab, Probe-Input, was
ist jetzt, äh, hä, das hab ich doch legit eben grad noch ausgeführt, hat er vorher
schon nicht compilert, hat er vorher schon nicht compilert, ach fuck, der hat vorher
nicht compilert, shit, was, no matching function, ah, da muss ich wahrscheinlich irgendwas
incluiden für, ach, er hat vorher nicht compilert, na geil, lul, was muss ich da incluiden für,
hab ich, dann hab ich, dann hab ich falsche Parameter, nul, nul, nul, ähm, ähm, ja,
was, no conversation from AV-Input-Format to AV-Input-Format, hä, const, AV, muss ich
da einfach const davor schreiben jetzt und dann funktioniert's, diese Sprache ist einfach
zu Sixthead für diese Welt, ähm, ich hab mich schon gefreut, dass es funktioniert,
aber es funktioniert immer noch, jetzt hat er auch kompiliert, was wird das, wenn du
Glück hast, siehst du's in zwei Sekunden, wenn das jetzt funktioniert, mal gucken, mal
gucken, ob das funktioniert, warte mal, da ist es, das Video wird gestrebt, Leute, es
kommt ein bisschen langsam die Daten rein, oder, es ist nicht so schnell wie vorher,
die Daten sind ein bisschen langsam, wahrscheinlich hab ich zu viel Debug-Ausgabe oder der JavaScript
Interop ist zu langsam, sind noch Sleeps drinne, ja, da sind jede Menge Sleeps drinne, also
das Sleep hier ist okay, aber das ist so ein Sleep 1, das sollte jetzt nicht, das, soll
ich das mal rausmachen, ich mach mal die ganzen Finger hier raus, das ist noch ohne Ton, das
geht aber prinzipiell auch mit Ton, also JavaScript C++, also okay, bisschen HTML, das ist HTML
JavaScript und es ist C++ und das C++ wird nach WebAssembly transpiled, kompiliert kann
man wahrscheinlich sogar sagen, und läuft dann im Browser, bam, guck dir mal, die Sleeps
sind raus, Leute, jetzt flutscht's, massive, massive flutsch, hallo, ach, what, guck dir
mal da, es geht einfach, auch ganz schön viel CPU-Leistung, ich mein, ich geb, also,
es sind viele Sachen an der Stelle äußerst eklig, das hier mit diesem EM-Wall finde ich
total abartig, da müssen wir auch mal ein To Do hinschreiben, wir machen auf jeden Fall
weiter, ob man das nicht irgendwie, keine Ahnung, direkt in Ram schreiben kann oder so,
also vielleicht kann man ja sagen, hier, Alloc-Buffer, blablabla, und dann return ich den Pointer
zu dem Buffer und wandel das irgendwie um oder so, mal gucken, mal schauen, vielleicht
geht das schneller, aber, ja, das geht, ja, dann erzähl mal, wie das funktioniert, also,
es hat schon eine ganze Weile gedauert, ob ich auch rausbekommen habe, wie man das überhaupt
mit diesem Interop-Krempel hier macht, so, das nächste, was mir nicht gefällt, ist der
Global Champ, der Global Champ ist ja nur da, damit ich mir merken kann, wo ich stehen geblieben
bin in meinem Buffer, also was man jetzt natürlich da wunderbar verwenden könnte, wäre irgendein
Iterator, aber Iterator in C++ werde ich garantiert nicht programmieren, das ist nichts,
was man machen will, ordentliches Async Await gibt's ja in C++ leider nicht, also insofern,
wir könnten eine eigene Klasse machen, wir könnten eine eigene Klasse machen, da machen
wir da eine Member-Variable rein, wo wir uns das einfach merken, wo wir gerade sind, leider
nicht, leider nicht, wenn das ging, wäre ich wirklich froh, aber man kann leider nicht
sagen Reader, Read Buffer Size, das war cool, das geht nicht, der Read it, wie er lustig
ist, vielleicht, das können wir auch noch, to do, kann man Buffer Size irgendwie bestimmen,
auf der anderen Seite ist das aber gar nicht so wild, weil der liest jetzt, der liest
halt so viel ein, wie er für notwendig hält, guck mal mal, wie oft reloadet der eigentlich,
wie oft reloadet der, das hatten wir doch hier an der Stelle hier reload, Print F, reload,
wie viel hat der da eigentlich, wie oft hat er reloadet, also wie oft hat er nachgeladen,
so ein Zeug, aufkompilieren mal hin, das ist immer so furchtbar langsam, er reloadet öfters
mal, das ist ok, also wir streamen, wir streamen den Kram wirklich gerade, zwar selbstgestricktes
Streaming, aber es funktioniert, es wäre cool, wenn man die Buffer Size angeben kann, also
wir könnten wie gesagt, wir könnten eine eigene Klasse machen, dass man diesen Kram
hier irgendwie bisschen, wobei eine globale Variable, wo wir dann rauslesen, brauchen wir
wahrscheinlich immer noch und nachdem, ich meine ohne Scheiß hiermit kann man wirklich
leben, das ist halt, es gibt ja nur einen Lese Thread und da muss man sich keine Gedanken
drüber machen, einen Lese und Schrei, weil der löscht ja auch Sachen, nachdem das immer
aus dem gleichen Thread passiert, kann da eigentlich nichts schief gehen, es ist halt
unschönes Fuck, dass man das überhaupt so kompliziert machen muss, könnte ich die Buffer
Size angeben, wäre das halt mega, neuen Overwatch 2 Content gesehen, nee mega, es wäre mega,
wenn man irgendwie hier die Buffer Size angeben könnte, vielleicht kriege ich das aber auch
in Javascript irgendwie hin, dass dieses Ge-Chunk in Javascript irgendwie passiert
und dass ich dann einfach nur noch hier sagen kann, read, eine Q bringt mir nichts, weil
dann lädt er einfach unendlich nach, ich muss schon blocken, wenn ich noch am verarbeiten
bin und ich glaube, dass das an der Stelle auch passiert, weil guckt mal, ich rufe dieses
Read a Read nur auf, wenn meine Daten leer sind und in der Zwischenzeit blockt das, so
passt, passt, ich bin, ich bin immer geistert, das klappt, das ist cool, nee, der streamt
das jetzt, der streamt das jetzt, also das ist cool, es gab noch irgendwas kleines, was
ich anpassen wollte, aber ich hab's vergessen, was ich machen wollte, zu viel, zu viel geschwätzt,
keine Ahnung, ich mein, man könnte noch hier, man kann hier vieles machen, man könnte zum
Beispiel hier noch mal schauen, dass der auch guckt, ob es einen Videostream gibt und dann
nur weitermacht, wenn es einen Videostream gibt und sowas, aber jetzt gucken wir uns
das nächste Mal an, wie das, wie das ist mit, wie man das gescheit macht, aber also das
Stream, das Stream geht jetzt ja, man kann jetzt, wir machen jetzt mal eine Sache, dass
man auch wirklich sieht, dass es funktioniert, es sind 30 FPS, das heißt 1 durch 30, 1,33,
ok 33 Millisekunden, also nur, dass man mal sieht, dass das von der Idee her auch ordentlich
funktioniert mit dem Streamen, ich mach mal kurz hier die ganzen Return-Dinger raus, die
Print-Fs, ja und hier auch das Print-F raus, so und jetzt, was hab ich gerade gesagt, was
ich noch machen wollte, ich hab, ich hab wehres Zeug erzählt, aber, achso, ich wollt euch
zeigen, dass das funktioniert, ja, also lassen wir den mal hier, keine Ahnung, 30 Millisekunden
sleepen, dann solltet ihr sehen, dass das Video ungefähr realistisch schnell läuft,
genau genommen müsste man dort jetzt die Zeit messen und gucken, wie viel FPS das Video
hat und sich das ausrechnen, wie viel man sleepen muss, minus die Schleifendauer, übrigens
bei der Gelegenheit, wisst ihr, wo wir gerade, wir waren ja heute ein bisschen auf C++ rumgehackt,
guckt mal, jetzt läuft das auch ganz gut, guckt mal, jetzt läuft das ungefähr in normaler
Geschwindigkeit und hier unten reloadet das schön, guckt, der spielt den Buffer leer
und dann reloadet er, C++ hat eine richtige Pains-Champ-RP, was das angeht für Time,
pass mal auf, ich muss euch jetzt zeigen, wenn ihr lachen wollt, wenn ihr lachen wollt,
ich zeige euch das mal, C++, C++ Timer, pass mal auf, ihr lacht euch kaputt, wait a minute,
der macht das, ach ne, der macht ein Timer mit thread sleep, ne, das meine ich gar nicht,
ihr lebst, ja, pass mal auf, kackel, alter, lull, guckt euch das mal an, guckt euch das
an, was ist das, alter, ich mein, ok, chrono, steady clock, was auch immer, now, das lasse
ich mir noch gefallen, ja, das ist ok, ich mein, heutzutage könnte man so schreiben und
könnte so schreiben, ok, aber was zum Teufel ist denn, so Milliseconds, also dieses Ding
jetzt wirklich ernsthaft, seriously, warum, meine ganz bescheuerte Frage, warum kann man
nicht einfach sagen, auto, lull, warum kann man nicht einfach sagen, endminusbeginn, und
das ist nanoseconds, das ist ja ein, ne, das ist auch nicht, da muss ich das selbst umrechnen,
also, warum gibt das hier überhaupt nen Wert zurück direkt, warum gibt es nicht irgendwie
ein duration objekt, oder ein duration struct oder meinetwegen, und dann würde ich dann
da drauf gehen und sagen, ok, time, ms, oder so, ja, oder lull, time, was, eh, keine Ahnung,
seconds, sowas, warum nicht so, das wäre doch easy, aber stattdessen haben wir standard
chrono duration cast dahin und, also, warum muss man das so kompliziert machen, ja, es
ist doof, dass man sich dafür ne eigene Klasse bauen muss, ich mein, warum, warum machen
die's einem mit dieser komischen Sprache immer so schwer, übrigens hier das Video, ne, funktioniert
wunderbar, also, nur mal so für alle, die in der Zwischenzeit dabei gekommen ist, was
da dran jetzt so nice ist, ok, Video ist vorbei, was da dran so nice ist, guck mal, das ist
ein PAL-Video, ein PAL-Video, 30 FPS in MPEG 2, das kann ein Browser normalerweise nicht
abspielen, ehm, ich muss das übrigens gar nicht mehr hochladen, fällt mir gerade ein,
das kann ich jetzt, das mach ich jetzt, das dauert 2 Minuten, das machen wir noch schnell,
dass es direkt anfängt, also, ehm, setup, jetzt brauchen wir nämlich alles gar nicht
mehr, on file change brauchen wir alles gar nicht mehr, wir brauchen einfach nur das hier
jetzt, es ist auch total egal, was ich übergebe, solange ich mich nicht selbst über, oh,
ich lass es sein, ich lass es bleiben, ist gut, ehm, theoretisch kann ich jetzt irgendwas
übergeben, ist egal, leer, und es sollte direkt, warum fängt das jetzt nicht direkt an, sollte
das jetzt nicht eigentlich direkt anfangen, eh mein, von der Idee her, info, undefined,
im
Das ist, das ist ne gute Frage, können wir mal nachgucken.
Guck mal, wie das Video einfach funktioniert.
So pork.
Achja, ich, ich, ich eier da wirklich so lahm rum in dem Video.
Ja, du kannst, du kannst was abspielen, was der Browser nicht so portet.
Ich mein, also, am Bad Rand, ich weiß nicht genau, ob ich das richtig, wahrscheinlich
nicht.
Ja, also wir haben es ausprobiert, Performance mäßig, Performance mäßig ist es tatsächlich
nicht ganz brauchbar.
Multi-Threaded packt das 1080p 60 FPS, kommt natürlich auf die CPU an, äh, das ist, äh,
dieses Pixel-Battlefield, Battle-Dings, ich hab Battle-Bit, glaub ich, hieß das, das
ist ein Video von mir, von, von YouTube, was ich zum Testen genommen hab.
Äh, was soll ich sagen, also wir haben die Performance getestet am Anfang, der schafft
1080p 60 FPS mit meiner CPU, ja, das ist ein bisschen übertakteter, der 8700K und ich
hab vier CPU-Cores in der VM, der ist da allerdings schon ziemlich, wie soll ich sagen, so, ziemlich
am Limit, ja, oh, jetzt lädt er aber heftig nach.
Da flitzt er, siehste, deswegen muss man das dynamisch machen mit dem Sleep und nicht
hard-coded, weil die Frames auch unterschiedlich lange brauchen, ähm, und, also, er schafft
sogar 4K, also 4K 60 FPS schafft er nicht, aber 4K 25 FPS schafft er, rein CPU-decoded,
das ist natürlich nix gegen den HTML-Video-Element mit GPU-Acceleration und sowas und GPU-Decoding,
aber dafür kannst du damit halt auch noch Sachen abspielen, die der Browser kann und
damit kannst du alles abspielen, ja, geht mit dem Video, guck und er downloadet automatisch
und die Seite fängt jetzt zum Glück auch automatisch mit Spielen an, jetzt muss ich
jetzt, eigentlich kann ich diesen blöden, diesen blöden Button da jetzt endlich wegschmeißen,
ja, weil, Results brauchen wir alles nicht, wir brauchen bloß noch das CACVAS zum Video
reinrendert, ha, der Name, Alter, ja, das CACVAS brauchen wir, wir benutzen WebGL-Shader
für die, für das Umwandeln von UF420 nach RGB, deswegen rendert er das überhaupt so
schnell und mit zu wenig CPU-Last, aber, wohlgemerkt, das hab ich einfach nur copy-pasted, guck,
der macht hier Massive-Five-Header, das hab ich aus irgendeinem Blogpost copy-pasted,
das hab ich mir nicht selbst ausgedacht, weil, das ist ja nicht das richtige Image, achso,
Input, ja, Input, okay, fort, okay, gut, das brauchen wir auch nicht mehr, das Fake Sleep
brauchen wir auch nicht mehr, das hier brauchen wir auch nicht, das hier brauchen wir auch
nicht mehr, so, viel besser jetzt, wir plocken den Main-Thread doch überhaupt nicht, wie
kommt da auf die Idee, dass wir den Main-Thread plocken, ich plocke den Main-Thread nicht,
wo block ich, wo block ich angeblich den Main-Thread, Anzeige ist raus, hier wahrscheinlich, ja,
ne, nach Format, ach, das Outen plockt den Main-Thread meint er, ja, den kurzen Ruckler,
den muss man aushalten, wenn man das, theoretisch, wenn man das richtig machen würde, ja, mit
dem, also, dass die, ähm, dass es nicht ruckelt, bzw. dass es nicht zu schnell läuft, theoretisch
müsste man dann hier irgendwie sowas machen, nur so ganz, nur so ganz grob, man müsste
quasi hier irgendwie sagen, Chrono, ähm, Begin, oder Now, ach ne, geht ja nicht, Clock,
irgendwie was mit Clock, Steady Clock, System Clock, ich hab keine Ahnung, ähm, Now, Auto
und Now, so, da müsste man sich merken, wann der Schleifendurchlauf angefangen hat, und
dann müsste man, was, High Resolution Clock, warum ist das ein Struct und das ist ein,
ähm, was ist das, ist das ein Interface, was ist denn das da, Template, weiß nicht, ob
ich wirklich High Resolution Clock brauch, so, zumindest, da könnte man, könnte man
jetzt messen, quasi, was jetzt ist und wie lang es gedauert hat bis hier, irgendwie
End, End, machen wir das gleiche nochmal, End, so, und, äh, dann sleepen wir quasi
nur, äh, End minus Begin, ach so, das sind jetzt Nanoseconds, oder, Auto, Duration, ne,
das ist jetzt gar nix, hab ich Begin gelöscht, ach, Now, ich hab's nicht Begin genannt, ich
soll das Begin nennen, so, Duration, Nanoseconds, so, und dann sag ich, wir wollen sleepen,
äh, was ist Nanoseconds to Milliseconds, Nano, ähm, Durch, 100.000, Moment, Count, Durch,
eine Million, so, ups, so, schauen wir mal, ob das Sinn ergibt, was ich hier getrieben
hab, Chrono Duration Cast, ja, das ist hässlich wie die Nacht, das hab ich oben schon gesehen,
warum, was ist die Daseinsberechtigung überhaupt davon, also, warum, ne, das funktioniert nicht
ganz, was ich da getrieben hab, was ich da gemacht hab, also, ich, ich kenn das, ich
hab das eben gesehen, aber das ist halt, abartig, richtig abartig, Mann, Milliseconds, und dann
muss ich sagen, Duration, ne, geht das überhaupt so, ey guck mal, guck das mal an, what the
fuck, Alter, was ist das hier, was, das C++-Cremium ist einfach ein riesen Pepega-Verein, wer
sich sowas ausdenkt, ah ja, du hast recht, du hast, du hast recht, du hast, du hast recht,
ich brauche, ich brauche vor allem nicht den Sleep, das ist totaler Schwachsinn, was ich
gesagt hab, ich brauche den, ich brauche die Zeit plus die FPS, plus die FPS, also sprich,
wie lang möchte ich sleepen, für die FPS, und dann minus, minus die Duration, also quasi
begin, end, ganz, ganz schrecklich hier, ganz schrecklich, so, in dem Fall sind es 30 FPS,
ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, die FPS gibt es glaube ich bei Kodak irgendwie, FFM-Pack,
AV-Packet, FPS, warte mal, die, die gibt es, wo gab es die FPS hier auszulesen, Auto, FPS,
Flash, das war, war das der Input, gab es das am Input, i, ne, Kodak, ne, Stream, ne,
ne, ne, das, das hier funktioniert so nicht, das ist G-Bait, das ist G-Bait, Raid, Airframe-Raid,
das, FFM-Pack-Frame-Raid, oh, wie kriege ich die Frame-Raid von dem, das hab ich schon
gemacht, das weiß ich aber aus dem Kopf nicht mehr, das hier ist G-Bait, das hat bei mir
noch nie richtig funktioniert, aber ich mein ich kann es ja mal ausgeben und wir gucken,
was, was er, was er ausgibt, Int, ok, also, guck mal mal, muss dann übrigens gleich
was essen, so, Print F, weil Format immer noch nicht geht, so, und was war das andere,
Mensch, Num, genau, guck mal mal, was ist das für, ich weiß gar nicht warum ich das
gemacht, das hätte ich eigentlich das nächste Mal, was jetzt, was jetzt los, Sleep, ahja,
das hätte ich eigentlich das nächste Mal machen können, aber egal, auf, AHA, 30, anscheinend
stimmt das, 30, 30 FPS, so, Sleep-Time ist 1 durch Desta, äh, das machen wir da oben,
Sleep-MS, 1, Moment, das sind nicht Sleep-MS, was, was hab ich denn jetzt hier, ähm, Moment,
das ist ein Int, ein Int funktioniert nicht, kann ich, kann ich sagen, Float oder so, dann
checkt das und macht's einen Float raus, ne, ähm, kann man, so, ich brauch einen Float
auf jeden Fall, brauch Kommas, so, jetzt haben wir was, jetzt bekomm ich da 0,033 oder so
was raus, äh, ne, ist 30, 0,0, also sprich, ähm, ich muss das nochmal mal 1000 rechnen,
mal 1000, damit ich das ganze in Millisekunden hab, ne, guck mal, ob das realistisch erscheint,
genau, also das da, Sleep-MS, Sleep-MS minus Duration, Chat, passt das, was ich da gemacht
hab, ich mein, da könnte höchstens was Negatives rauskommen, ich hoffe mal, dass wenn was Negatives
rauskommt, der einfach, schreib einfach 1000 durch FPS, I've had her, haste recht, das
ist viel besser, äh, nicht so ganz, es ist ein bisschen langsam, da müsst ihr überlegen,
an welchen Stellen ich das abfrage, das ist, aber es geht in die richtige Richtung, ja,
das ist ein bisschen zu langsam, das ganze, was, 33 FPS, ne, 30 FPS, 30 FPS sind das,
so, ha, das sind 33 Millisekunden, die das sleepen soll, minus die Duration, wie das,
wie das gedauert hat, ah, da müsste man sich jetzt noch was überlegen, aber, das, das
geht, geht auf jeden Fall schon in die richtige Richtung, ja, guckt, was hat er denn in Sleep-MS
überhaupt drin, da stehen jetzt, Leute, was ist Print F, was ist Print F für nen Float,
L, ne, was, was ist ein F, einfach nur, easy, keck, das ist ja mal logisch, dass es ein
F ist, mein Int, ein Int ist ein D, weil, jetzt, oh, oh, Monkeys, Alter, mein Browser,
der explodiert gleich, oh, was, Signature-MS, ach so, ich hab hier was vergessen, Sleep-MS,
Versuch mal Steady-Clock, ich glaube auch, dass High-Resolution-Timer nicht das beste
ist dafür, aber schauen wir mal, ja, 33 ist gut, naja, ganz ehrlich, Leute, das kommt
hin, die Geschwindigkeit, ich glaube, das Game ist schlicht und ergreifend nicht schneller,
ich glaube, das Game ist exakt so, oder, ne, das ist doch ein bisschen, ein bisschen zu
langsam ist es, ja, da muss man sich noch was überlegen, aber das stimmt doch hier,
32, 33, irgendwas, gucken wir mal, wie das mit Steady-Clock ist, da ist wenigstens mein
Browser nicht komplett am Eskalieren, also wenn man das Lokal abspielt, dann sieht das
so aus, ja, ja, okay, okay, okay, da bräuchte mir jetzt irgendeinen Five-Hand-Game-Proggers-Mann,
der mir sagt, wie ich das ordentlich time hier, was kommt hier, was, blöde Frage, was
kommt hier unten jetzt eigentlich raus, so, und er sagt hier, now am Anfang, rendershit
und sagt end, so, also was kommt eigentlich bei Duration raus, wie printet man denn eine,
ah, okay, was war das, LLD, 5N64, oder einfach nur D, Duration, oh ne, LLD, LLD, Five-Hand-Format-Zeug,
ja, das kann sein, dass der ein bisschen langsam ist, weil ich bin mir nicht sicher, wie das
mit dem, mit dem runterladen dann funktioniert, ach, da sind Minus, da ist Minus, hat er Probleme,
weil das Minus ist, Moment, warum ist meine Duration ein Minus, ach, lul, falsch rum,
ne, das Decode ist nicht zu langsam, das Decode geht mega flott, wenn man gar kein Sleep-Trainer
zum Beispiel, Big Muffs, ja, Leute, so ist das gut, so ist das gut, das sieht doch schon
deutlich besser aus, oder, das ist jetzt normal an der Stelle, das sieht doch jetzt schon deutlich
besser aus, so, die ganzen, die ganzen Prints mal raus, alles klar, das ist nice, so, gut,
noch einmal, gucken wir uns das einmal noch einmal im Fullscreen an, es kann er, es kann
er auch Canvas hochskalieren, wenn ich das mit dem Canvas hochskaliere, ist es halt auch
mal ein tausendfache schneller, als wenn ich das FFM-Pack hochskaliere, so, Massive-Pal-Auflösung,
Leute, Fullspeed encoded im Browser, frisst halt ganz schön CPU-Leistung, ja, also lange
am Smartphone streamen würde ich damit nicht unbedingt was, was hat er denn hier immer
im Desktop, naja, guck doch mal, der langweilt sich, der langweilt sich komplett,
guck mal, der langweilt sich komplett, mein Browser, ah, da muss immer mal Garbage collecten
zwischendurch, wie gesagt, mit der Auflösung geht es halt krass hoch, weil es komplett
CPU, ja, nach dem nächsten Stream pack ich es auf Git, das ist jetzt aktuell noch nicht
so, da muss noch ein bisschen was dran gebaut werden, ah, wie groß das Wasom-File ist, Moment,
gucken wir nach, das Wasom-File ist, das Dist, nee, der ist deutlich kleiner als Blazer,
ist egal, 2,9 MB und das andere ist irgendwie, also es geht klar, ich mein, da ist ein komplettes
Wampack drin, Blazer alleine ist die Mono-Runtime ja schon 8 MB oder so, Leute, ich muss schon
Licht anmachen, sag mal, warum muss ich Licht anmachen, ist schon wieder die Sonnenwände
überschritten oder wie, also wird es schon wieder dunkler abends, ihr wisst, was ich
meine, also es wird immer abends dunkler, es wird schon früher dunkler abends, warum
muss ich der Licht anmachen, was ist das hier, Sonnenuntergang, Sonnenuntergang Frankfurt,
morgen, 17.6., ok, es wird noch länger, da wird es wieder weniger, wann ist es anmachen,
am 28., ist kaum Unterschied, das geht ja auch nicht komplett linear, das geht am Anfang
glaube ich ein bisschen schneller, nee, das geht am Anfang langsam, dann geht es zwischenzeitlich
wieder ein bisschen schneller und dann geht es wieder ein bisschen langsamer, also wie
viele Minuten am Tag dazukommen, jetzt sind es nur eine Minute zwischenzeitlich, sind
es glaube ich sogar irgendwie an die drei Minuten, am 21., das macht kaum Unterschied
hier, Leute, richtiger Fiveheader Kram hier, was für Files lädt der dann am Anfang hier
runter, das gucken wir jetzt noch schnell, so, habe es kaputt gemacht, was, Worker, ok,
der lädt diesen Webworker, den brauche ich gar nicht mehr, Worker, weg, der braucht den
Webworker, ich habe keine Webworker mehr, wobei, bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, ob nicht
vielleicht die C++ Rats über Webworker laufen im Hintergrund, man weiß ja nie, nee, ok,
warum lädt der immer noch Worker, der soll keine Worker mehr laden, die Datei gibt es
angeblich gar nicht mehr, ach nee, Moment, ok, nee, das ist normal, nee, nee, nee, das
ist normal, das ist nur, dass ich auf Worker extra Worker Sachen hinlege, nee, nee, das
ist normal, das ist, weil ich das mit P-Threads wahrscheinlich kompiliere, jaja, ja, ok,
ist aber trotzdem vollkommen ok, guck mal, es sind insgesamt, ach nein, das ist ein Webworker
aus mp4-info, nee, hier lädt der Worker GS von, ich habe keine Ahnung, das gucke ich
mir jetzt aber nicht näher an, dasselbe, was auch immer, ist egal, wunderbar, also, das
ist gar nicht so viel, das sind so, keine Ahnung, ja, sagen wir mal, 3,2 MB, das geht
vollkommen klar, ja, kann ich, guck, da läuft das Video, und nicht nur einfach so, wir haben
aber noch eingebaut, dass es automatisch Sleep macht für die korrekte FPS-Anzahl vom Video,
ja, das ist die korrekte FPS-Anzahl vom Video, und du siehst hier unten, dass er nachlädt,
guck, immer wenn, immer wenn Reload steht, immer wenn Reload steht, lädt er sich neue
Chunks vom Server runter, und dank, dass es awaited wird, plockt das auch nicht den Browser,
ok, das hier ist anscheinend sehr größenintensiv, weil hier lädt er total viel, der Vorteil
ist davon, dass du Videos abspielen kannst, die dein Browser normalerweise nicht abspielen
kann, ohne, dass du serverseitig das Transcoden musst, also ohne Scheiß, ich könnte mir
durchaus vorstellen, dass, zum Beispiel, irgendwelche Streaming-Anbieter, die auch Fernsehprogramme
streamen, die also auch Fernsehprogramme anbieten, dass die in Zukunft sich überlegen, wenn
der Browser das unterstützt, ob die das nicht gleichzeitig Transcoden, weil das spart einfach
Rechenleistung, bei ihnen, weil das wird ausgestrahlt in MPEG 2, und die müssten es Transcoden
zu H.264, auf der anderen Seite sparen die sich wahrscheinlich damit auch JavaScript
und Logik, weil sonst musst du ja unterscheiden, das ist nicht mobile-friendly, nein, das ist
überhaupt nicht mobile-friendly, wobei bei Fernsehprogrammen geht das halbwegs, das braucht
auch nicht so viel, würden die das Rohmaterial nicht einfach konvertieren, ja doch, braucht
das Rechenzeit, das ist das, was ich meine, ja, machen sie und werden sie wahrscheinlich
auch weitermachen, aber es ist eine wirklich coole Sache, dass das funktioniert, das finde
ich äußerst pog, finde ich das, äußerst pog, poggy, poggy, oh man, ich dreh langsam
durch Leute, 5 Stunden diesen Müll gemacht hier, alter C++, das hat mich, diese Sprache
ist so ein Rotz, alter, schlimm, echt schlimm, wenn ich mir sowas hier angucke, und wisst
ihr was das schlimmste ist, was ich seit langer Zeit in C++ gesehen hab?
Das hier, warum das nicht in C sharp gemacht ist, ja, hätte ich gerne, hätte ich gerne,
aber WebAssembly C sharp ist bis auf Blazer noch nicht so der Wahnsinn, Blazer ist auch
nicht so der Wahnsinn, ich mag Blazer überhaupt nicht, du hast da, also WebAssembly C sharp
hat ein paar Probleme, erstens, ich glaube der Interop mit FFmpeg hätte sich sehr schwierig
dargestellt, dass ich FFmpeg WebAssembly verwenden könnte mit C sharp, vielleicht hätte man
das irgendwie per p-invoke dann da sich was stricken können, keine Ahnung, aber das wäre
schwierig geworden, aber die Performance von C sharp WebAssembly ist auch unterirdisch,
also erstmal lädt er irgendwie eine 8 MB Mono Runtime runter, keine Ahnung, weil es C++
ist, achso, Beginn, ja, weil ich, weil ich vom Anfang was löschen will.
Ja, so kleine Slowdowns hat er zwischendurch schon noch, aber insgesamt, insgesamt geht's,
ja und weil, wie gesagt, C sharp lädt sich dann irgendwie erstmal 8 MB Mono Runtime
runter und fängt dann erstmal an, das zu interpretieren zur Laufzeit, was mega langsam
ist, das Ding kann, der JIT funktioniert nicht richtig von C sharp Mono WebAssembly und Ahead
of Time C sharp sind sie auch gerade erst dabei, das wird mit.NET 7 deutlich besser,
dass du C sharp Sachen auch Ahead of Time kompilen kannst und nicht Jitten musst, bin
ich mal gespannt inwieweit das dann gut funktioniert, das könnte für WebAssembly ordentlichen
Performance Boost bringen und auf der anderen Seite, du musst halt den ganzen Kram dann
downloaden dafür, also im Prinzip, es ist von der Performance nicht drinnen aktuell
das mit C sharp zu machen, es ist auch vom Interop mit einer C-Library eklig das in C
sharp zu machen und das wird halt wahrscheinlich nichts, das sehe ich auch in nächster Zeit
nicht, ich glaube, in dem Fall kommt man echt nicht drumherum als das mit C++ und, also
ich muss sagen, diese M-Scriptensache ist wirklich nicht schlecht, also die machen da
wirklich vieles, das hier oben ist halt Paintschamp, da können sie, also dafür können sie nichts,
das ist halt eklig hier, das gucken wir uns auch das nächste Mal, ob man das nicht irgendwie
schöner hinkriegt.
Ne, Mono im Browser wird es nicht geben, ich meine, die könnten vielleicht, vielleicht
einen Mono Browser Addon anbieten, aber das bringt ihr ja wieder nichts, das hat ja keiner
installiert, das ist dann fast schon sowas ein bisschen bitter wie Silverlight, wenn sie
Mono Browser Addon anbieten würden, ich glaube, da sind wir drüber raus, ich glaube, das
will keiner mehr, ja, manchmal ruckelt es ein bisschen, wisst ihr, warum es manchmal
ein bisschen ruckelt, gehe ich mal ganz stark davon aus, weil der ist fertig und dann muss
er nachladen und dann slows down kurz ein bisschen, weil er irgendwie ein paar Millisekunden
länger braucht, irgendwie so, ne, nice, okay Leute, wollen wir jetzt noch ein paar Videos
gucken und ich futter was oder nicht, weil ich bin noch eine Stunde on, danach bin ich,
dann bin ich fort, wird gucken, okay, es gibt noch kein GitHub, was mache ich das nächste
Mal, schön, dass du den Weg hierher gefunden hast, komm hier auch gleich Subsribe, so muss
das sein, übrigens danke Leute für die Subs, die es heute gegeben hat, ähm, guck grad
nach, Subscribers, also, Garfrilo7, danke für den Sub da, stimmt, da hast du eben schon
was geschrieben, Merp ist am Start, der Ozu Moment, wusstest du, dass Ozu ein Open Source
Projekt ist, was es auf GitHub gibt, äh, der Rüpel, xmax4, Leute, es haben bloß 5 Leute
für diesen Pain hier heute abonniert, was ist denn da los, wie soll ich denn davon hauptberuflicher
Fulltime C++ Streamer werden, was klappt, das klappt so aber nicht, ich hätte euch
glaube ich öfters mal erzählen müssen, dass man mit einem Prime Sub, ähm, kostenlos einmal
im Monat einen Streamer seiner Wahl unterstützen kann, ich hätte öfters Sellout machen müssen
ja, oh ne, ich hab, ok, sorry Leute, ich hab mich verguckt, ein paar mehr waren schon,
ich hab bloß 4 Stunden zurückgescrollt, ich bin ja heute so lang on, der Max hat noch
Subscribed, Kalf hat Subscribed, MrMuGame hat Subscribed, Ddouble, Dankeschön für
den Sub, so muss das sein, PorcGredo hat Subscribed, der seine dicke Katze gegrüßt
haben wollte, ja, PorcG, so ist das, so wofür ist das, PorcG, sehr schön, MrLolf, Passive
Subscriptions, also ich hab's in Wishlist Studio Code verwendet, das war Pain's Champ
in the S quasi, das war richtig eklig, also in Wishlist Studio keine Ahnung, wie da das
Support ist, Wishlist Studio Code war abartig, oh hör mal bloß auf, wenn ich den Kram nicht
mehr sehen muss, bin ich froh, in Santi, danke für den Sub, so was schauen wir uns denn jetzt
an Leute, gibt's irgendwas Gutes, was verdient eine medizinische Fachangestellte, wahrscheinlich
viel zu wenig als das, was jemand machen will, ok, dieses Video wird mir die ganze Zeit vorgeschlagen,
warum?
Der hackt keinen Online-Shop, weil da werden's Hacking-Content und Hacking-Content mag YouTube
nicht, das ist, ok, steht dahinter, IT-Security-Einführung, alles klar, ok, keine Ahnung, kann ich zum
Content nichts sagen, ist mir jetzt zu hart, der Kost, ich schalte mich kurz auf Just Chatting
um, Just Chatting, Monka SC++ überlebt, oh mein, noch nicht, überlebt, ok, ok, ok,
weitere, OK!
Gut, então, GitHub stellt Atom ein, ich weiß nicht was sie versprochen haben, da juckt
ich mich jetzt nicht so, ich fand Atom eh schon nicht so geil, Leute, wirklich Barbeque
Pit Boys, ich hab Hunger, ich muss was essen, Leute, Barbeque Pit Boys, das haben wir schon
die schlage nächstes mal geguckt yeah the miracle of time also was haben wir hier bacon egg double
cheeseburger gibt es überhaupt it videos auf youtube nicht clickbaits ja meine und und
meine auch teilweise aber muss sagen der florian ist äußerst seriös mit seinen videos also da
ist nichts geklickt bildet das stimmt auch immer wer ist ja eigentlich dass ich so richtig wieder
wieder reingekackt haben wir haben uns überlegt wir machen ein video schon schon zwei monate
her oder so ich habe das sogar vorgeschlagen und jetzt ist es wieder komplett eingeschlafen
ja ich müsste mich eigentlich echt mal melden und sagen jetzt lass uns mal aufnehmen was
hier an mir liegt er hat ja schon zweimal gefragt wieder da hier kirkona kirkona auf geht's
sekunde leute ich muss was musik ausmachen kirkona style auf geht's alter wie das tropft
moment es ist aber nicht der richtige sprecher das ist nicht der richtige das ist ich brauche
den ha ha ha den ich brauche den original sprecher wo ist er ist er gestorben oder was
wo ist der original sprecher ich hoffe nicht wo ist der original sprecher leute das ist
nicht mehr ich brauche den original sprecher ey wo ist er ja genau den den brauche ich
so der originale ok sliders excellent jawoll der hört sich komisch an ich habe echt ist
er vielleicht echt gestorben das wäre das wäre ganz tragisch hier so hier hört er
sich normal an was es leckt leute legt es leck nix ok auf gehts das gucken wir uns jetzt
an so ich esse jetzt mal schnell nen tostbrot oder sowas wartet mal ich hab übelst Hunger
die
Ohoho!
Oh ne!
Erstmal hab ich das richtig gesehen.
Erstmal ein komplettes Schälchen Fett rein.
Ich hab den Toaster nicht am Schreibtisch. Da steht ihr schon seit zwei Stunden.
Bisschen an was mich das ein bisschen erinnert. Kennt noch jemand Epic Mealtime von früher?
Die gibt's zwar immer noch, aber die guckt keiner mehr.
Bacon Strips! Bacon Strips! Bacon Strips!
Ich mein immerhin guck mal da sind so minimal was ist denn das? Kürbis?
Oh ne!
Er kann ja nicht sein, dass das oben noch erkennst. Da muss auch noch Bacon drauf.
Und danach Herzinfarkt. Ich hoffe nicht, dass der wirklich einen Herzinfarkt hat.
Oh Mann!
Vor allem die Musik wieder im Hintergrund.
Wow!
Was für ne Sauce? Westerscher?
Ich hab's nicht verstanden.
Aber jetzt mal ernsthaft, das musst du nicht in nem Grill machen oder?
Das kannst du genauso gut in nem Ofen machen.
Na ja.
Ich hab schon Ansprechende das gesehen.
Ich mein schmecken wird das bestimmt. Es besteht ja zum größten Teil aus Zucker, Fett und BBQ Sauce.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Bei so viel Kakao-Nut-Time.
Oh was gucken wir uns denn jetzt? Gibt's irgendwas gescheites zum angucken? Ich bin immer noch ganz fertig mit Essen.
Oh was das?
Was ist denn ein Privattier?
Ah, mehr Buba Shorts?
Ah, vielleicht nachher. Das ist schon wieder überdramatisch gemacht.
Lebt von seinem eigenen Money? Also jemand, der eine sehr selbstständige Firma hat und damit Geld verdient oder was?
Geil. Muss man fancy Wort.
Vielleicht ist das einfach nur reich. Weil eh cringe wer kein Geld hat.
Die Stomps. Leute ich muss mal gucken. Ich glaub die Stomps waren nicht so gut die letzten Tage über.
Leute soll ich in meine Stomps App gucken oder soll es lieber sein lassen?
Werde ich jetzt geschockt gleich? Alter! What the fuck?
Ach du Scheiße!
Minus 1800 Euro die Woche. Geil. Minus 3000 Euro fast übers Jahr. Poggers. Das hat ja richtig gelohnt mit Stomps.
Keckel. Massive Keckel.
Ich hole das auch. Ich werde das garantiert nicht jetzt verkaufen.
Was können wir uns jetzt mal anschauen? Herausforderender Alter. Das ist mir zu... Das gucken wir jetzt. Ich weiß zwar nicht warum mir das empfohlen wurden letztens, aber das gucken wir jetzt.
Alles klar?
Was genau passiert da?
Ah das sind die Teilnehmer. Verstehe.
Okay passiert noch was?
Okay. Okay. Lass mal überlegen. Ich predicte die dicke gewinnt.
Der sieht nämlich aus als traut er sich nicht.
Okay. Die dicke wird nicht gewinnen.
Du hast nicht nur beiden Stomps verloren.
Gebe alles. Okay. Pech gehabt. Die hat sich dafür absolut nicht interessiert. Falsch predictet.
Okay. Wieder die dicke weiße. Ich tippe immer auf die dicken.
Auf. Jawoll. Massive prediction.
Alter hat die kurze Beine. Die schleift ja fast auf der Erde.
Also ich tippe wieder auf die dicke.
Okay daraus kann man auch content machen. Eigentlich ist das richtig five hat weil soll ich viel machen muss man da glaube ich nicht für.
Das ist doch wahrscheinlich ein paar Minuten gemacht.
Okay.
Einfach mal vermuten. Also genau ist das bei Chico weiß man das nie.
Five hat er.
Die hat die hat viele mit so kurzen Beinen.
Ja ja ja.
Das ist die dicke am Anfang oder die sich nicht rüber getraut hat. Die traut sich immer noch nicht rüber.
Das ist die die abgechillt hat bei der ersten Runde.
Und jetzt frisst das Lametta auf toll das genauso würde ich mir das paar Chico auch vorstellen.
Na der hat es aber drauf mittlerweile. Die hintere hat es wieder nicht gecheckt.
Auf. Gas geben.
Der andere musste ich erst mal putzen im Bälle Bar. Na gut.
Die dicke gewinnt ich sag's euch die dicke macht das gar kein Ding.
Die rechte easy guckt euch mal hier wie die schon rauf wie die schon los.
Das wird Chico nicht so interessieren ins Wasser.
Chico hat kein Problem mit Wasser großartig.
Sie holt auf.
Jetzt aber jetzt hat es aber ja alles.
Also elegant ist was anderes jetzt ja.
So ich habe keine Ahnung warum mir dieses Video empfohlen wurde.
Aber jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Was auch immer wir wissen ich weiß es auch nicht genau aber.
Jetzt wissen wir es.
Eigentlich ziemlich unsinniger Content aber ist mir lieber als vieles andere.
Die Burger Battle naja McDonalds und Burger King gewinnt da garantiert nicht beim Burger Battle.
McDonalds Burger King ist abwärts im Nordsee da ist ja nirgends wo gescheite Burger dabei.
YouTube hat alles richtig gemacht ich habe es zu Ende geschaut genau.
Also aus irgendwelchen Gründen ist YouTube sehr scharf darauf dass ich mir die Spider Girl Transition angucke.
Ich weiß nicht genau warum ich habe das Video drei vier mal jetzt schon ignoriert.
Aber YouTube meint nein Max das musst du dir angucken.
Nein das gucke ich mir nicht an.
Kann ich nicht sagen not interested oh es ist weg es ist weg.
Aber not interested kann ich nicht machen weil ich nicht eingeloggt bin.
Chat wieder.
So gibt es irgendwas interessantes was wir jetzt noch gucken können.
Huge news huge news alles klar.
Ok ich gucke mir eine Minute an und sage euch Leute es ist nicht big.
Einfach einfach nur dass man Chibayt sieht.
Macht euch keine Sorgen ich gucke es mir nicht komplett an.
Ein Playlist Update krass Alter huge.
Huge news Alter was ein Stumpfsinn Alter und die Leute klingen es doch an.
Und tschüss.
War doch klar dass es keine huge news gibt.
Was programmers are also human.
Was war das Gott tier HTML Programming.
Ach Emmet das ist ja schon uralt.
HTML ist mein Lieblingsangriff.
Emmet ist schon ist schon all school.
Programming heisst das kann sich auch jemand dran erinnern.
Bevor Emmet hieß bevor es Emmet hieß das hieß mal Zen Coding.
Das weiß wahrscheinlich keiner außer Boomer.
Aimboard cheats are evolving.
Irgendwie ist nichts dabei was ich mir angucken will.
8 simple smart home automations anyone can do.
Ok ok.
Moment ist das der haben wir das nicht schon geguckt.
Das ist nicht der mit dem Fernseh der in der Klappe ist.
Ne das war was anderes.
Das war was anderes.
Insane.
Moin Erbsenraube.
Unbefristet Namensvertrag.
War das das wo du geschrieben hast dass du dich beworben hast.
Ich blicke da nämlich nicht mehr durch.
Weil wir hatten in letzter Zeit so viele Leute da.
Azubis die sich beworben haben.
Leute die Praktikantenstellen gesucht haben.
Ich blicke nicht mehr durch wer was gesucht hat.
Was ist ein tumble dryer.
Gibt es das auf deutsch trock trockner oder was.
Einfach ein trockner.
Wäsche trockner.
Ja das habe ich mir auch überlegt mal so zu machen.
Aber wisst ihr was deutlich einfacher ist.
Einfach den Stromverbrauch messen.
Ja genau das ist die viel bessere Variante.
Das andere mit diesem Vibrationssensor ist Pfeif hättiger.
Aber manchmal sind die einfachen Lösungen die besseren.
Trommel trockner.
Guckt mal habt ihr es gesehen.
Ganz viel watt pro sekunde.
Ok der Witz war schlecht.
Das war das was ich vor vier Stunden mal erzählt habe.
Das weiß wahrscheinlich keiner mehr.
Da ging es um Leute die sagen watt pro sekunde.
Und das andere habe ich schon wieder vergessen.
FPS.
FPS pro sekunde.
Wo ich gesagt habe die haben sie nicht mehr alle.
Ich meine sowohl FPS pro sekunde als auch watt pro sekunde ist beides ziemlich erschwachsinn.
Ja gut ich glaube tatsächlich dass das eine Automatisierung ist an die schon mehr oder weniger jeder
der sich ein bisschen mit Smartphone beschäftigt hat gedacht hat.
Also nicht unbedingt jetzt explizit beim Wäsche trockner.
Aber dort wo gern was vergessen wird ja sei es Waschmaschine sei es trockner sei es Spülmaschine
oder was auch immer da wo man das oftmals nicht mitkriegt.
Und das ist tatsächlich eine äußerst sinnvolle Geschichte.
Und lässt sich in der Regel mit einem Smart Plug ohne Probleme umsetzen.
Das verhindert eine unbekannte Spülmaschine.
Hier ist ein Kuchen für ein guter Junge.
Ich mag das auf unserer Waschmaschine machen.
Aber kein Grund dass das gleiche Prinzip nicht auf einen Tischwascher, Tummeldreier oder etwas ähnliches kann.
Die nächste Automatisierung ist für unsere Shoppingliste.
Also ich bin mir sicher du warst hier vorher wo dein significant anderer dich gefragt hat etwas aus dem Shop zu holen.
Und du kommst da und vergisst komplett was das Ding war.
Also ich habe eine Shoppingliste auf unserer Dashboard geplant,
dass jeder von uns gehen kann und so viele Items wie wir wollen...
Weil ich möchte mal eine...
Es gibt durchaus auch die Möglichkeit sich sowas schnell zu notieren mit einem Zettel.
Oder aber mit einer x beliebigen Notiz App, also man braucht nicht unbedingt ein krasses Home Automation Dashboard mit Einkaufsliste.
Daily Liquid.
Morning Wake Up Lights.
Daily Morning Announcements.
Sendman Alexa Clock.
Door Window Open Notifications.
Flashing Nights when someone comes home, das verwirrt die Katze eher.
Sleeping Computers.
Was? Okay.
Table Lights for me.
Speaking of computers, I am really bad for leaving my computer on all the time when I'm not at home.
Achso der macht Wake On LAN oder so das komische Zeug.
Bind Day Notifications, ja das habe ich auch am Start.
Bei mir sieht das, das hat man sogar im Video schon gesehen.
Ja bei mir sieht das so aus.
Sekunde ich zeige euch das mal kurz.
Home Server.
Genau bei mir sieht das so aus.
Ja.
Bei mir sieht das so aus.
Da kann man nachgucken.
Biotonne.
Gelbe Tonne, was weiß ich.
Plastikkram.
Plastikkram, alles Müll und Papier.
Das zählt dann auch immer runter.
Am Ende des Tages, aber so dass man quasi immer für den nächsten Tag sieht, dass man es nicht vergisst.
Gibt es da auch eine API? Ja da gibt es eine API.
Es gibt tatsächlich relativ gutes Addon.
Waste Bin, Home Assistant.
Ne nicht Waste Bin, Waste Collection.
Ich glaube das hier ist das was ich habe.
Das habe ich als Datengrundlage.
Ich glaube das ist es.
Das habe ich als Datengrundlage und dann habe ich Customized, wie das im Frontend aussieht.
Und das kann auch deutsche Sachen.
Also das kann Supported Service Providers.
Ja guck mal hier was das alles kann.
Das heißt der zieht sich das vom Service, von irgendeinem Web Service.
Das heißt du musst eigentlich einmal nur, falls du eine API brauchst für diese Sachen, brauchst du den.
Du musst aber eigentlich einfach nur einmal deine Adresse eingeben.
Und schon kann er für immer dein Müllkalender abrufen.
Sehr praktisch.
Ja Tanken 71 war am 3. Januar.
Da war meine Stonks auch noch nicht so schlecht.
Meine Stonks auch, ich habe 3000 Euro Minus.
Seit Anfang des Jahres.
Computer Hardware, okay Zeitmeier.
Da kann ich mich doch dran erinnern.
Was macht er eigentlich, macht er noch andere Videos außer das?
Ach da.
Jetzt weiß ich auch wer die ganzen alten Festplatten,
immer auf Ebay kauft.
Hättest du mal in Dirk Müller Fonds investiert?
Wer ist Dirk Müller?
Ist das irgendwie so ein Skamars Typ der dir erzählt, wenn du mir das Geld gibst wirst du reich oder?
Alter
512 des Ketten, Scanner
16 Festplatten
Krass
Nicht schlecht.
Das ist, das ist schon äußerst Pork.
Zieht halt ein bisschen was an Strom.
1300 Watt pro Sekunde.
Warum eigentlich pro Sekunde, warum nicht, warum nicht gleich pro Millisekunde?
Er hat Beschleunigung genau.
Ja das ist es eigentlich wirklich.
Das ist irgendeine Geschwindigkeit oder irgendeine Beschleunigung ja.
Aber krass.
Also da steckt bestimmt tausende Stunden Arbeit in Form von programmieren, basteln, überlegen das bestimmt nicht ohne.
Krasser Scheiß.
Gute Alternative für, dass man nicht Copyright gestreikt wird oder?
Es klingt fast besser als Oldschool PC Speaker Musik.
Also Rechner früher, also ganz ganz viele Spiele früher, die haben das ja versucht um PC Speaker zu machen mit dem Sound.
Das war halt keine gute Idee.
Reddit mit einem 300, nee Moment, Moment mit einem 300, was ist denn das?
Das ist kein 56K, kein 33K, das ist 0,3K.
Oder 0,03K?
Es bootet.
Ich will nicht, dass es lädt.
Naja ich mein der braucht, komm mal, es gibt aktuelle Windows Rechner die sind auch so langsam.
Im booten zumindest.
Du hast vor ein paar Jahren nur 6K Modem, nee nee du meinst was anderes.
Du meinst ein DSL 6000 Dings.
Du meinst kein Modem.
Du meinst ein DSL Modem.
Wo ist die was stehen geblieben hier?
Massive Disk Drive.
Ich muss ja sagen ich fand so diese alten Dinger mit dieser Mechanik immer cool.
Ich bin nicht alt genug, dass ich so krass viel Disketten Zeug gemacht habe.
Also ich meine ich kenne noch die Wubble Disketten, ich kenne auch die 3,5 Zoll Disketten.
Ich hab die natürlich auch verwendet, aber nie so exzessiv wie da manche.
Ich hab nie Coral Draw installiert von 54 Disketten oder sowas.
Aber Pippen Dance ist immer noch tatsächlich der hat damit eigentlich gar nichts mehr zu tun.
Ich hatte dann später eher CD und CD Brenner und sowas.
Aber die Mechanik, also ich mochte so dieses Feeling von Floppy Disk reinstecken.
Schönes Monochrom Display.
Duochrom.
Es ist ja immerhin blau und weiße.
Und theoretisch sogar ein paar Farbstufen noch.
No Phone Number.
Ein Akustik Koppler.
Okay, jetzt kommt aber der richtig Oldschool Shit raus.
Der Gift Player ist von mir.
Moment, es gibt ja doch tatsächlich, es gibt immer noch Dial-Up Dinger.
Also Akustik Koppler war auch vor meiner Zeit.
Man muss jetzt wählen und dann muss das Telefon oben drauf legen.
Auf dieses Ding, was er da in der Kiste hatte.
Ich.
Akustik Koppler, genau.
Die Einwahl dauert ein bisschen.
Terminal.
Übrigens, wenn ihr sowas seht, dann dann wisst ihr auch, warum Wim.
Ich meine, bei Wim war es noch extremer.
Wim konnte man damals verwenden für Rechner komplett.
Ohne grafische Ausgabe, wo der jeden Scheiß noch ausgedruckt, ausgedruckt hat.
Jetzt weiß man auch zu schätzen, dass Wim so Operationen hat, wo man nicht so viel den Cursor bewegen muss.
Und wo man nicht so viel hin und her scrollen muss.
Da gab es schon HTTPS.
Ich glaube, der ist auf irgendeinem selbst auf irgendeiner selbstgebauten Kiste, wo er sich mit dem Terminal gerade drauf verbunden hat.
Also wo er sich per Dial-Up drauf verbunden hat.
Das war damals garantiert nicht.
Damals gab es auch noch gar kein Reddit und so.
Boah.
Und das ist schon ohne die ganzen 40 MB JavaScript oder so, was das runterlädt.
Das will ich auch noch mal kurz reingucken.
Oh, oh, oh.
Kannste komplett klicken.
Und wie gesagt, das ist nur rein das HTML, da ist noch kein JavaScript und sowas dabei.
Also das Ding kann ja auch gar kein JavaScript.
Nur HTML.
Immerhin, ich meine, Reddit geht auf, aber man kann sich keinen Inhalt angucken.
Schon hart, dass ich überlegt.
Das ist doch schon outdated.
Wenn man sich überlegt, dass ich damals mega fasziniert war, von 56 Möglichkeiten im 56 kam oder Internet zu gehen.
Also es hat sich schon echt einiges getan.
Vieles von dem, was ich mir so vorgestellt habe, wie geil es in der Zukunft wird, hat sich dann nie wirklich in die Richtung weiterentwickelt.
Wie gesagt, ich dachte mir ja auch damals, als ich ganz viel MMOs gespielt habe, wie geil MMOs 2020 oder so sein müssen.
Es kam in den letzten 10 Jahren kein gescheites MMO mehr raus.
Na, fliegende Autos, da habe ich das nie gedacht.
Ja, gucke ich manchmal.
Ich habe sogar schon von dem Typ früher, die noch.NET Tutorials geguckt, die er gemacht hat vor 10 Jahren, 20 Jahren, 20 Jahren.
Der hat ja früher.NET Zeug gemacht.
Jetzt macht er irgendwie nur noch JavaScript Zeug und ab und zu Go.
Was macht der da eigentlich?
Ist mal eine ganz dumme, jetzt wollte ich ja nicht drüber fallen.
Ich meine, das ist Kriegsgebiet.
Warum fliegt er denn freiwillig dahin? Will er irgendwie russisches Flugzeug auf dem Kopf haben oder?
Also, was macht er denn da?
Ich bin aber ein Abstandschütz.
Wenn man nicht da ist, muss es gefährlich.
Jetzt passiert einem nichts.
Nur im Volo-Zimmer, ja wahrscheinlich. Wahrscheinlich waren sie noch nicht mal da.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was YouTube hier für Vorschläge macht.
Ist gerade nichts dabei, großartig.
Ein bisschen halt auf das, was man sonst so geguckt hat, aber nicht so wirklich gut passend gerade.
Das gleiche Studio, wo die Mondlandung war.
Das ist gut gealtert, aber na gut, wurde permanent upgraded wahrscheinlich.
Ihr wisst ja auch, es ist ja allgemein obvious bekannt.
Die internationale Raumstation, die ist ja auch unter Wasser und gar nicht im Weltall.
Das weiß man ja.
Das sieht man nämlich daran, dass Wasserplasen im Hintergrund manchmal hochplubbern.
Das weiß man doch.
Und wenn ihr das nicht wisst, dann müsst ihr euch einfach nur mal an den richtigen Stellen unabhängig informieren.
Und dann wisst ihr das auch.
Common Sense, genau.
Das sind genauso wie die Leute, das dreht mich ja auch immer, die einfach ihre Kamera nehmen.
Irgendwie einmal links und rechts langschwenken und sagen, ich sehe nicht, dass die Erde gekrümmt ist.
Ich sehe, es ist flach.
Das ist alles flach.
Da denke ich mir auch so, Alter, habt ihr euch mal eingeguckt, wie wenig Krümmung das ist.
Die Erde ist ziemlich groß.
Das ist nicht so, dass du einfach mal in eine Richtung guckst und sagst, ganz klar, da sehe ich es nicht.
So einfach ist das nicht.
Also das ist schon recht umfangreich, worauf wir.
Ich wollte mir mal überlegen, wie viele Millionen Menschen gibt es jetzt auf der Erde?
Und die passen da alle noch locker drauf.
Und es gibt immer noch viele Gebiete, wo keine sind.
Also es muss schon eine gewisse Größe haben.
Man kann die Elkümmung auf vielen Stellen beobachten.
Aber wenn du dich halt einfach nur irgendwo hinstellst, an irgendein Feld und mal von links nach rechts schwenkst und dann sagst du, da ist ja nichts.
Es gibt auch den Trick, du kannst, wenn die Fotos gut gemacht sind, kannst du die Fotos in ein Bildbearbeitungsprogramm nehmen und dann zusammenstauchen.
Dann sieht man das besser.
Also keine Ahnung, YouTube empfiehlt nichts Gescheites.
Aber Leute, ich sehe auch, es ist 20.10 Uhr.
Ich glaube, das war der längste Stream seit langem.
War aber ein Poggers Stream.
Schön, dass so viele da waren.
Wir haben ja heute auch richtig was Gutes geschafft wieder.
Über 3000 Leute waren zumindest laut Anzeige da, was aber verbackt war.
Heißt der Channel wirklich Hyper S?
Alles klar, Leute. Wir sehen uns. Bis dann. Macht's gut.